Do.
We are here live with Kurt Metzger,
the president of the
Donald Trump fan club,
and he's got to let us
know about the campaign.
Hopeful and exactly what's going
to happen with Mr. Trump wants,
he becomes president curb.
Uh,
I'm all for Trump.
President is going to,
what'd he say?
He's going to be the,
the biggest economic turnaround.
Big Promises.
He got fired from NBC
men to hear about that.
He's so,
and Donald Trump,
he got fired.
Oh,
for his apprentice sharing show.
Yes.
He got fired from the fire and ironic.
And for him it is.
He says he's going to sue though.
He'll have the last laugh.
Why is he suing them like they fought?
Did they find him for,
well,
he made a bunch of disparaging
comments about Mexicans,
about people crossing
the border and it was,
you know,
he just was talking,
he was talking like a,
like a rich guy with a no sense
whatsoever that he can hold it down.
I love that.
Yeah.
I was like,
I love that bladder where we just
can't like Choli and hide it.
You gotta let it out.
But,
uh,
I'd ever blame like the corporation,
you know,
the has to fire whoever for a thing.
Like that's what I expect them to do.
It's a business.
You know what I mean?
Like I would never have put that on them.
If I got fired from something,
I would like to sue them after that.
Seems fucking a little crazy.
I think he just sues
anybody who gets in his way.
He's a fucking steamroller,
a steam roller of lawsuits when though,
I don't know.
I mean he has a rock solid
contract to sweat TMZ said,
so that's why he's doing it.
Okay.
So they do pageants.
So they fired him from that.
And then Mexico said that they won't
put a woman in his beauty pageant.
So over ms,
what does it miss?
Universe is that Miss Universe universe.
So,
uh,
it's a rough week for a
fucking multibillionaire.
They have Donald Trump are in
Jada's are like going crazy though.
In Mexico.
Everyone's beating like really Trump.
Oh that's hilarious.
Yeah,
they get mad,
man.
I don't,
you know,
that's not like,
I guess cause I'm going the east coast,
it's not like a thing.
Like I don't,
I don't have like any strong
feelings about immigration.
Like I saw,
I didn't even know how to
like Dan Culture on my show.
Right.
And her,
she wants to about her book Adios
America right about like the illegals are
coming and I'm like,
I don't really have any like well I
don't give a shit if they come like why
can't we go after their employers?
Yeah.
Why can't you?
Why can't,
Okay Jane,
why,
why can't you,
what's the thing about
Mexico and the California?
Is it Mexico?
You could just drive to and a lot of
people over from Mexico to really,
even though you got a good point,
there really isn't a place like that.
And these coasts except for Cuba,
Cuba's got,
you know,
the Miami thing or a,
Miami and Cuba right
next door to each other.
And so a lot of Cubans,
did you have friends or like I,
one of my best friends from a college
says do from Peru with telling me how cube
is a utopia.
That was his term.
It is if you like 1950s because yeah,
I guess I'd like nobody's on an inner
tube floating to Cuba that I've ever heard
of that that's just why I don't buy
well they have some good things,
you know,
they seem to be like really nice people.
They have great sense
of community and family.
Have you ever been there?
No,
but I wish I could tell you why I may go.
Um,
but I'll tell you off here.
Sorry folks.
It's a secret.
Uh,
but,
but you will,
you see down there for real is like these
incredibly restored old 1950s American
cars.
Oh yeah.
Cause that was the last
time they were getting cars,
so,
right.
Yeah.
Look at all these cars.
This is Cuba.
Like this is like,
oh,
I can finally fill my fifties a musical.
I don't know how they're doing this.
Well,
you know what,
that's really odd.
He's or how they make sure that
these bodies stay restored.
If there remanufacturing,
I'm,
I don't know how they're doing that.
Like some old cars,
they take like some old cars and then
people will make new body parts for those
old cars.
Cars are meeting people.
Joke did you knew why?
But look at this.
This is cube.
I mean there's a few new cars in there
and the one on the left hand side,
but there's a lot of this man.
That's cool cause weird.
Right?
You said you're going for sex stories.
Him Jesus Carp match skirt.
I don't know.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know how long that looks
fucking kind of cool actually.
How long have they been
using these old cars?
Like that is older than the embargo.
Right?
The embargo happened in the sixties
three really built on back then.
You know what I'm saying?
So like these are really old cars though.
Like that up on top.
I think that's a 57 or 56 Chevy.
That blue one to the to the middle there.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that's a 50s like a late
50s car like that taxi looks like at
the morgue and mini mini chair.
That's a real tax.
The Egg,
the Nanu Nanu egg in 1952 Oldsmobile.
Wow.
So there are a few like see this
fairly modern cars in the background.
It's a modern truck,
but I guess you see a
lot of these old cars.
It's kind of wild man
time machine.
You know,
if you go back there,
Dick Charles,
cool.
Well they're all cool,
but they're driving them.
It's like driving a living room.
There were hardened.
They're just the dumbest fucking,
the dumbest shape ever
for like getting around.
I think that fucking Fiat,
this stupid shape that you got commercial.
Yeah.
He's running like the
women want to fuck it.
It's the dumbest,
it's shaped like the ropes.
They have weird commercials.
Their commercials almost always involve
fucking remember one time there was a
kid in the backseat and all the bras
and all the girls getting changed in the
front seat and all the bras and
everything of flying on him and he's just
sitting there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I,
you know,
I'm fucking hate those commercials for
the same reason you would read like a
feminist blog hating that
commercial pub for a different,
like I hate it too,
but I think they hate it for a reason.
Different than my reason.
Right.
I'm insulted by it.
They hate it because
it's objectifying women.
It's all women are just there
to be sexual play things and
throw their bra and your
face while they're driving.
Yeah,
I know the difference.
I everybody really believes that
that really changes you so much.
Like the little extra extraneous shit
that you look at changes your perceptions.
It bothers me cause I resent
the idea that I would just,
Oh tits.
It's all okay,
I'll buy it off the boat.
It's like,
that's annoying to me that
someone would think I was at dumb,
but uh,
I don't understand the object.
You know,
it's the worst objectification.
Those fucking,
uh,
like top 10 worst beach body lists.
You've seen that shit.
That ain't for men.
Who's reading that?
That's when my girlfriend,
like,
which,
which girl has the shitty his body.
I would never even look
at a list like that.
How is me like the Burger commercials?
Like nicer,
you know?
Unless there's someone on there
that you used to think was hot,
then you might check out,
see how far the slide has gone.
Like,
Ooh,
you might look,
you might look in a train wreck way.
But yeah,
those things are for women,
you know?
But it's some women,
it doesn't mean define like,
it's like if you're creating characters
for fiction and the idea that you can't
create a con,
you know,
you can't make a slot.
You can't make a girl who's
all fucked up in the head.
Well they,
they exist in life.
Okay.
And if you're making fiction,
your fiction doesn't necessarily have to
represent anything other than what's in
your head.
What's the wacky story
you're trying to get out?
You don't have any obligation to
use a certain amount of Asians.
You don't have any obligation to use a
certain amount of white people or black
people.
Your obligation is to
make something cool up,
make it up,
pull it out of your head.
Well look,
people will worry about
entertainment like that.
That's a very good,
when I was religious,
that was our one of the
Jehovah's Witness Dude.
Like every fucking thing
I watched like smart,
like smurfs was off limits for
some fucking bullshit reason.
Right.
They wouldn't let you watch the SMURFS.
Yeah.
I mean,
so why it really,
but there's,
I don't know where there's some demonic
thing with that and it's all these
fucking,
and then,
uh,
I remember that as Simpson,
somebody came in and gave a talk,
brother Tucker,
his name was,
he was like the traveling
overseer was his title.
Alright.
And he would come and like
give talks in the congregation.
I was in meetings like
three nights a week.
So he gave this whole fucking talk about
all this shit that like how he t was
bad because he,
yeah,
cause he healed the boy and you're like,
you know,
who do we know is the
only person who can heal?
Like I might start believing
ut is the real Jesus.
That's the fear.
And then the Simpsons had
rebellion against authority
with bar and disrespect of
like your elders.
So that's so I could hear the mother's,
well,
I'm not like my kid.
Watch it.
I could hear them chattering after that.
Like that's what the shit is now.
It's like what is,
what's the representation?
It's not propaganda.
So Shit,
just candy.
You know?
So we were talking about
this before the podcast to,
do you think that some like overtly upset
PC people that what they're doing is
almost like a form of like protecting
lord almost like a form of fighting
against blasphemy charge my church,
I remember all of them that were like,
oh well you something like every
lunch with that same behavior.
I believe that 100% I think you're right.
What is the exact same thing?
Yeah.
I don't even listen.
I don't even mind them.
As long as you act trying to get me fired.
I don't want,
you can say whatever,
you know,
but if you want to criticize,
I'm not against criticism.
Right,
right.
That's fine.
Just do I have to be fired?
Just can we not do that part of it?
Well that,
that,
that is where you find out like
exactly what kind of people they are.
Like what exactly are
they trying to accomplish?
Are they trying to engage in
discourse with a reasonable person?
You're reasonable guy,
you'll have conversations with people,
but that's the thing they
want you instantly labeled
as an unreasonable person
who is not to be debated.
Well,
you shouldn't even have to bring it up.
You should just know what
the right thing is to do.
Remember the Anti Seinfeld like,
well,
you know,
so I felt,
by the way,
Chris Rock said the same thing,
right?
Yeah.
About what college is.
But he's allowed to,
yeah.
That was not sent in.
Seinfeld come down and it's like,
well,
he's irrelevant and an old man something,
which by the way,
that's like saying someone's fat.
Yeah.
Like what?
I don't see the difference in Ad Hominem.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean it's diffusing his,
his argument and what he's saying is,
you know,
with Jerry Seinfeld was saying was that
the colleges are too PC and they'll call
you on everything.
And then with his daughter,
they don't even know what the fuck these
words mean and what constitutes that.
And that's exactly right.
I don't think that PC ruins comedy.
Like people who are funny.
It's still funny.
It kind of fucks up audiences.
Right?
So we both,
I have the same goals.
One of these PCP,
like I think people treat be more
sensitive to each other and all that shit.
Right?
I do as well.
But their system is not
going to create that.
Just going to create fucking
people that shut down at buzzwords.
Right.
So that's not helping.
It's not accomplishing anything.
It's also a game.
There's like a,
there's a total that's being run.
Yeah.
And one side people trying to catch
you for things they can catch you with.
And it was just like what happens with
cops when you started giving cops the
ability to start right now?
Tickets and you give them the ability to
play this game and this game is to try
to get the bad guy.
You're in it,
you're involved in a game when
you're in a game with them too.
And their game is to get offended,
right.
Find some shit to get offended
and then they find it.
I got one,
I fucking gotten one.
And they get that one.
They want to parade that one out.
They want to publicly shame.
It's like game of Thrones,
shame,
shame.
That's what they're doing.
It's like a,
it's like talking to bill
collectors to near like watch.
Please don't swear sir.
Oh,
I can't help you with him.
I think I said like scumbag about,
it's unbelievable.
Watch your language,
sir.
That's like that.
That's just an easy out.
That's a grocer.
I like it.
I,
I can be reasoned with.
So what with some of his
argument that talks to me.
I'm not in trenched.
You understand?
So just,
if you're going to educate me,
do it.
I'll,
I'll listen to you.
You were involved in something like that.
W W w what was going on where someone was
trying to fire you for something from,
uh,
there's uh,
this,
uh,
what do you call it?
Remember Sam Morel?
That it was like,
it was,
it was the great rape joke.
Or if a 2012,
this is a great big chunk,
that whole fucking thing.
Daniel tosh thing.
Yeah.
So it was so Sam morale,
Yusef had show,
uh,
but he was having sex with his
woman is making them realize,
oh,
he's having sex is black homie.
I was making him really uncomfortable.
She kept using the n word and he goes,
you know,
no.
Right.
So somebody would a
whole article about that.
So the jokes like whatever,
throw a joke.
But there was a whole thing
about how fucking terrible he is.
So I did a thing with him where we said
the person that wrote this article is
not a real person.
Okay.
And when she was something we invented
to make some points about free speech,
and I had a couple people
on Facebook say like,
oh,
the Jig is up.
And so it's spread pretty
quick that she's not real.
Okay.
And she got fucking furious from that.
So she went through my whole Facebook and,
uh,
by the way,
like,
don't go on my Facebook.
I can't say that enough to people.
Like,
I don't need you and it's not good.
She went through,
she went through every post she could
find to just cut and paste shit out of
context.
Clearly Jim made a collage out of it,
which it's pretty awesome actually.
Like it looked pretty cool and uh,
had this thing and get me fucked,
but I was going to get fired,
but I had to have like,
I'd like call my PR,
have a call from my producer and shit.
I never even quaded my
job with any of this.
You know what I mean?
That was like,
well,
I'm dumb because I didn't realize
that would spill over into my,
you know,
my day job.
Well,
the fact that she's got the kind of time
to do that to someone who criticizes
her or makes like a little mock,
well she has a borderline per,
she has a mental illness,
like they should be committed for,
which I need to know.
I wouldn't even made a joke,
like I probably just like
a beautiful mind for her,
but I did that.
If I knew she had that,
I wouldn't have done that.
Oh,
right.
She has something wrong with her.
So people with that disorder,
borderline personality disorder,
they take shit way harder
than like regular folks.
Yeah.
So you did it in response for this
guy getting raked over the coals.
Jealous that he was getting attention.
That's a stupid I am.
I was like,
I have the offensive where's money thing?
So then I got my way to the next level.
You create you a so what was the wood?
Was the like the most
heinous infraction that you,
uh,
you were killing so much
shit,
Lord.
Uh,
no,
but you know what the,
it's called the,
uh,
the disturbing online
trail of Kurt Metzger.
Oh,
that's what it really does.
The name of the article.
Online trade.
It's like,
it's a real smear job,
dude.
I was shocked how like
smeary it was where I'm like,
wow,
you really manage it.
But I'd still,
wherever I go,
kind of funny.
But was like,
they still didn't even in the
effort to make it like bad,
but it's still the most unfair.
I can't even believe the amount of like,
like bullshit.
So it's pretty easy or somebody doing it.
And I think still to
this day I'll get random.
Like people are angry at me
and to this day from that.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
So it's like it can
affect you some something.
I know it's affected me somehow.
This bullshit fucking article.
Only in good ways.
Uh,
anybody that it gets offended by that
you didn't want him in the first place.
Anybody that can't see,
he can't like read through that and go,
wait,
what's going on here?
What is the,
the whole story.
Oh Oh they are mocking you.
And they said you weren't a
real person like you were.
You were a parody account.
Yeah I know you're angry.
Well cause people were putting up fake
accounts of her all over the place,
which I didn't tell anyone to do that.
And by the way,
I repeatedly,
my fucking stupid fans,
I can't ask them enough.
Not to like get involved in the thing
you had asked them to not get involved
because it's not your say they fall off.
Cause it's funny that in my fucking,
but it's not you.
It's fine.
I'm,
I washed my hands of
you doing anything day.
But she invites that because
what she's doing is online.
This is,
this is a totally open arena.
So like for you going to say like,
do your friends,
like don't,
don't give her a hard time.
Why is there a comment section?
Why is there a comment
section and writing nonsense?
Why did you leave a comment section?
Oh,
you're going to heavily edit the
comments section and I don't wanna like I
would've,
she's like,
somebody would have had them like
show if it hadn't gone to that.
You know what I mean?
Like I,
I don't want to Elian eat to people.
I want to get wet,
right.
Ken,
to come on my God damn podcast
because I'm not into like,
I don't,
I'm not trying to like,
what's it called?
By the way?
Race wars.
This meeting should always small and a,
we're going to serious pretty soon
for four weeks for like a trial.
But it,
it'll still be a podcast.
But uh,
yeah,
we have,
I'll have like,
just the whole deal.
It's a website.
Well,
at soundcloud and iTunes
you can get it on.
Okay.
And the last one we had,
Ann Coulter,
the managing editor of jazz rebel,
Jesus Christ girl,
Carolyn Castiglia,
who's a comic who like eight life,
she would,
you know,
it was great.
It was,
it was one of the best episodes.
I had a fucking slam poetry contest.
Really a slam poetry.
He goes,
dude,
you didn't see the fucking
youtube video of rape joke,
the Ms Slam poetry files.
No,
I missed it.
Oh,
it was brutal.
Do it.
Is it?
It's these two girls doing,
uh,
like each one says the next line kind of
slam po that they rehearsed their like
knock knock.
Who's there raped?
Wait,
what is this?
Is it a rape jokes?
Not fucking funny.
The crowd goes nuts.
It's no,
it's a real thing.
It's like slang.
If you go on upworthy,
that's what they love is like slam
poetry slam or what is upworthy?
You've never been on there?
No,
seriously.
It's like things you're supposed
to seems familiar to dig.
It's like a,
he was like an upworthy title.
Like this video of elephants getting
married will blow your mind and then you
see the like a little short
clip or else it's like this,
this little transgendered
girl explains it all,
blew me away.
You know,
like those are all the headlines and then
you're not doing shit
on Facebook where it,
yeah.
I hate that crap.
Where it says something like,
you won't believe what happens next
when this topic comes home from,
no,
no.
You don't understand Brian.
This,
it's like super lefty,
but this is like my old religious
jove [inaudible] literature.
But here's why,
you know,
celebrate diversity.
Don't squash it.
Here's why the president is wrong.
Like those kind of questions,
right?
Or those kinds of tasks.
A little bit more thoughtful
than the titles I would think.
But there's like,
you know,
Kurt Metzger is evil and,
and a problem for America.
Here's what's wrong with his comedy.
That's too specific.
No,
they're misleading.
It's always like,
get ready to have titles going again.
Going hold that and pull that back.
Yeah.
It's like all the,
it's,
it's a bringing,
I looked at one today where it was,
uh,
somebody screen scroll up to this.
Probably a lot of parody
sites of it too by now.
Okay.
How seven things that have
nothing to do with rape.
Perfectly illustrate
the concept of consent.
Wow.
Going to perfectly,
how crazy is that?
That the first thing to go to his rape?
Just a little bit of
rape obsession going on.
I know,
I know it's an awful heinous crime,
but God damn it comes up a lot,
you know?
I mean,
yeah.
I don't think they were wearing
these has to be raised more about it,
but I don't know.
I don't think there's anything
wrong with raising awareness,
but it seems to be,
there's like a massive focus on it.
Well,
you're not going to look,
law enforcement has to do their job,
you know,
all of those rape kits,
they have backed up.
Like that's fucking a big problem
with grain gets backed up.
Yeah.
Like they haven't checked them.
Like lots of the top Jamie.
But the things you see now is this idea
that just a little education is going to
stop this and you can educate
men not to rape but not a rapist.
That's what they do.
You're not going to
educate them out of that.
So that's why law enforcement
supposed to take care of that.
Well,
I mean you don't have
to tell me not to rape.
I get it.
That's a bad thing to do.
I think for sure there's something about
society's attitudes towards it would
make it more instead of teaching
women how to avoid rape,
let's raise boys specifically not drape.
Hey,
good luck with that.
That people that do that,
I like that pedophiles are like that.
They just come out.
You know what I mean?
Well,
they definitely think that
growing up in a certain household,
if your household is fucked up and you're,
you know,
your dad is a just a piece of shit towards
women and you show that you grow up
with that,
but you're not going to
change that with a cartoon.
You're just
the website them up.
They like,
there's nothing you can
do but lock them up.
But the only way to do it,
it makes any sense at all.
Would it be to somehow or
another raise better kids?
You know,
you'd have to like figure out how to
engineer that and that is not a small task
by any stretch of the imagination.
Maybe we could breed that out.
But I'm saying in the meantime,
while we're working on that w which
absolutely should happen also watch your
back,
you know,
until that problem is taken care of.
Like I shouldn't have to
change my bike up either,
but that,
uh,
you know,
it could get stolen if I don't.
This is seven things that
have nothing to do with rape.
Perfectly illustrate
the concept of consent.
It says,
want to watch pulp fiction guy says,
sure,
half hour later and I'm
not really liking this.
Let's do something else.
And the guy puts his hand on him and says,
no.
You said you'd watched the movie
so you're staying till it's done.
So he's gonna fuck that guy.
Basically.
No,
he's like,
it's like he's raping him by
forcing him to watch a movie.
Any guy that cares about whether
or not you watch a movie,
it's going to fuck you.
He's just waiting for
the drugs to take whole.
Let's double rape because double rapey
he's movie raping you and real raping
you.
Yeah,
he's a rape,
rape rapist.
These are all terrible.
Thank you for letting me borrow your car.
No problem.
The next week,
what are you doing?
Barring your car?
You said I could if anybody
fucks you for a week.
That Gosh deserves a trophy.
First of all,
this is a terrible analogy.
You can't take my car,
whatever you want it.
That's bullshit.
You said I could have at once so it
should be able to have it all the time.
Her car policy,
I get it.
It's car pussy and for a week
to do is fucking her for a week.
That's what they're trying to get.
You think this guy is so viral?
I don't know.
I can't even read these.
I know it's there.
No,
even like,
can I take anything off?
But they're hurting my brain,
but it's just such odd.
Who's his message for exactly
who is the message for?
You know?
It's Duh,
it's all de,
it's done.
Don't rape,
Duh.
Don't be racist.
No more.
The the fucking law and order commercial,
all the cast of law and order Svu.
Right.
You don't know more sexual assault,
which is a good call to stop it.
We're,
yeah,
we're all for it.
We're all for that.
They're going to do it.
I like,
I'm not one of these guys.
That's for it.
Okay,
so,
so then their slogans no more.
Which if there's one thing
that rapists understands,
just the word no.
So good work with that and then they,
they act like they can't even speak.
Did you ever see that?
It's all the actors from
Svu and they just go like,
ah,
no and it cuts the next one and he's like,
no,
no.
And they cut to Mariska.
Hargitay can we stop?
Can we just stop?
And it says sexual assault
is hard to talk about.
Is it really cast of law and order
Svu during a reap show for 16 years,
they can't bring it up now.
The whole show's rape and murder.
It's just the PME is fucking shit.
And they make money off of
rape and murder on that shit.
That's all that shows about
does porn for old people.
That's who watched you said Shit.
Oh fuck.
They get all titillated by murder shows.
Who's going to see that and just go,
I was going to go and rape and I know.
Right.
Shit.
All right,
Dan Florick
you got me.
Fuck.
Yeah.
That didn't help one person.
I bet.
No one single person.
Of course not.
None of that works.
You can't just tell people
to not do things well,
no,
they should be an environment.
Here's the thing you work on.
If somebody got raped that they feel
like they can report it like that's what
should make.
Yes.
That's the whatever the attitude is
to work on is the whole key to is
everybody's got to report
it when it happens,
which some people want.
Yeah,
and then,
Oh God,
what are you saying?
No,
go ahead.
Yeah.
Well remember Kilstein
was on Disney thing.
It drove me nuts when I want to come on.
The show was when he said
rapes worse than murder.
So that's not really helping a victim to
tell them they're better off dead than,
that's not really very kind.
Jamie,
do you understand?
That's how people don't report their
rate because they'd want to be known as
someone that something worse
than murder happened to.
Right.
You know?
No one ever stopped any sort of
crime by because of a slogan.
Give a hoot.
Don't pollute.
Maybe you know,
maybe,
maybe only you could fight for as far.
You know,
maybe you stopped some people
with one of those cards.
I think that could work.
Don't rape.
Hey,
pedophile rape.
Cut it out.
Pedos cut.
Stop fucking kids periods off the boys.
Let's call what it is.
Stop fucking kids.
They should have like,
oh,
we should make like really forceful ads.
Hey,
it's not cool to fuck.
Yes.
That would be a great ad.
Just three,
three words.
Stop fucking kids.
That's the whole ad.
I don't care if it's controversial or not.
You got to stop.
Yeah,
just stop.
I know you get a rise out of it.
You've got to come get,
he need a hobby.
Can't continue no more.
It was only one or two a year,
you know?
No more.
Imagine if you could find a kid
that could keep his mouth shut.
What a gem she found one.
Yeah,
no more of that.
If you are a pedophile,
it's gotta be the life of a pedophile.
It's going to be the most heinous prison.
Define your mind,
trapped in,
you know,
do you think that's an orientation?
Being a pedophile?
I literally have zero idea.
I what I imagine is that like some people
have schizophrenia and some people,
you know,
they develop all sorts of weird mental
disorders and multiple personality
disorder and these are,
the human brain doesn't always work right.
I heard schizophrenia is kind of
just a catchall for a bunch of shit.
You know,
it's not even,
I didn't realize how much psychology,
you know,
Scientology like bashes the shit
out of like psychiatry at Lake,
right?
They're not like psychiatry.
He's got a lot of bullshit.
I didn't realize compared to medicine
where it's not like they can't really
diagnose shit for real
to a lot of guesswork.
Did you know that?
Well they,
I know it in talking to people
that have taken antidepressants,
that's the take.
That's the robot.
Dick [inaudible] stick in here.
Um,
but Neil Brennan was on the other
day and he was talking about the,
this is one thing that a lot of people
may not know and I didn't know until I
started talking to people that take them.
The folks who take Ssri it,
they don't know like why
these things help people.
They really don't know.
Yeah,
I know.
You don't know which one's going to
work on you and they give you a bunch of
different ones to try this one out.
This isn't work.
Give me another one.
They give you another one.
Ooh,
I think we got it.
And you know,
you've got to figure out
what the dosage is like.
It's not an a,
it's,
it's a weird,
does that sound right to you?
I read this.
I don't remember where I read this.
So it could be just horse shit.
But you know,
people are supposed to
get suicidal on those.
Yeah.
Sometimes.
Yeah,
because some of them,
this could be wrong,
but it sounded interesting to me.
Uh,
they,
it kills us anxiety.
Some of them,
you know,
you have a certain amount
of anxiety in your,
in your nationally about ending your
life that's just naturally there to keep
you from doing that.
And when some of these drugs,
they even you out so much
where you don't feel that fear.
So if you really thought out your suicide
pretty well now you no longer have the
fear of committing it because you're calm.
So you're like,
oh yeah,
it's no big deal.
You just kill myself.
Well,
that was the argument for school
shooters and things along those lines.
I used to believe that too.
But then I found out when people say
they're not all some somewhere on Xanax,
so it's not all the same drug.
And that's like the very
catchall that's easy to answer.
Yeah.
What I was going to say is that they,
they don't,
they don't feel anything like they feel,
it doesn't bother them.
Like I frame it was on Zoloft and the
way she described it was she's like,
nothing bothered me.
Like nothing like my,
you carb beer into flames or whatever.
Creepy.
So if you had a desire to
kill someone for some reason,
wouldn't fuck with you the same way
it would if you weren't on something.
So yes.
So you get someone who's probably
wired wrong anyway for whatever reason.
Trauma,
abuse,
genetics,
whatever.
The reason is that someone could become
like that Colorado school shooting guy,
but he put someone like that on certain
medications and the way it interacts
with your fucked up brain is it allows
you to do heinous shit and not feel
anything about it.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know either.
But I mean that's,
I guess it depends how much of that is
just in you because I thought they calmed
you down too for some people,
but they have a different
effect on different,
it's like,
like those medicines that
they give people for Adhd.
Right.
If you took it,
you'd be like,
Danielle,
that's what happens when I do take it.
Yeah.
But if you give them
to kids who have ADHD,
apparently it calms him down.
He says strange way.
They like crash or something.
I don't fucking get it.
You know,
it was just fucking Meth,
man.
Wow.
It's a little different but slightly
that we give to Hitler pills now.
Hitler did you,
by the way,
did you see,
I think about his Hitler,
the junkie.
What a history channel.
It was all about his doctor feelgood.
Oh,
he had a doctor feelgood.
They didn't even know back then.
People were taking math.
I thought it was like a vitamin is that
it was that he was going to invite a
shot of meth.
He probably had a lot of energy and
then makes sense if you think about it.
They used to give that
to the fighter pilots.
Apparently the Germans came up with,
well,
the kamikaze is take it and they said yes.
Used to get good dudes to fly
their plane into ships and blow up.
Turn them in the human torpedoes.
They apparently they were
using crystal meth or drink.
That's amazing.
They could be that like
sure that their guys like,
uh,
God.
Emperor to do that.
You know that ball.
I'm really fucking turn that idea around.
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
I snot God.
there is no god.
Yeah.
When that happens,
when you see the entire city of operate,
how about the one guy who,
who escaped from Hiroshima and then
went to Nagasaki and they dropped it on
Nagasaki?
Oh yeah.
That's the fucking crazy man.
Out of both of them.
I mean,
can you imagine after that you're like,
you're never gonna believe.
What could you imagine what it must've
been like to see both of those cities
with nail the argument that
maybe they didn't need to,
didn't need to drop to like they
could've maybe just dropped the one.
They definitely got to drop one.
The actual argument,
I think we're talking about it yesterday,
is that they might not
need to drop anything.
Like the Japanese might've already been
trying to surrender and realize that I
am my yet.
Oh,
is that right?
Kind of thing we've got to do first.
I don't know if that's true.
You know,
like also I've heard that a,
we knew that the Japanese were going to
attack Pearl Harbor and we kind of let
it happen.
We pulled the over that too.
It's just always the
same and competence dude.
It's like could be I
fucking or the Illuminati.
I get nos fucking arguments all the time.
John Dam Illuminati.
They're looking at it right now.
You're already feel a bit of them too.
If they want me to draw triangles on shit,
I'm fucking so into it taking
place from the Illuminati.
I'd be happy to serve.
So they tried to get you fired
from the show and it didn't,
it didn't work.
But because I'm nobody,
so if they picked,
she picked like is she made
me pick the famous dude.
She could've made something
happen but she picked somebody.
Nobody fucking his heard of.
Do you think that's what they're doing?
They're just trying to get traction
and go onto somebody else's shit.
Right.
There's a lot of that right,
but you get forever because it's a good
cause you get away with shitty behavior
and shitty interaction skills.
If someone's like,
I'm geared towards like a
lot of people like all right,
well what's the,
what's going to be the liberal
or Conservative position?
And I'm identify as that so
I'm just going to go with that.
I don't really have even
taught me to think about it.
You know,
we should probably don't.
And you just go with the liberal
cause like that's just what it is.
It's just knee jerk forever.
Well I think it's really interesting
comparing it to religion,
comparing the mindset to cult
mindsets or religious mindset.
You have to be true,
right?
They just have specific things that are
suddenly a gospel that must be true and
you must ignore all the fucking evidence.
That's what I used to do,
to not believe in evolution.
I would ignore the shit that's not because
there's no way would I believe can't
be true.
I'm familiar with that.
Like this,
this rolling stone article that came out
where they were deceived by this woman
who claimed to have been
gang raped by a uh Oh,
right.
Well she set out to find how horrific.
By the way,
that's a real problem.
But you know that didn't
get served to well by,
by someone making it like the most
outlandish story that I've ever heard.
Yeah.
And uh,
but that's the thing she set out to find
cause she already knew it to be true
but,
but you know what,
I don't get how a,
I was watching vice did you
say the vice thing about it?
About Columbia and they're talking
about campus rape like oh how come they,
the school gets to deal with it at all?
The only answer I heard was because
convictions are hard to get in a court of
law and that might be
the only way to like,
I guess convict a rapist.
But so what he gets expelled,
like that's,
if someone rates you,
that's a good enough punishment.
They just get expelled from school.
So is that really what happens if they
don't bring it to a criminal court?
I,
if somebody knows telling me cause I
have no idea to this day why all these
institutions,
church or whatever.
Why is there anything where
they handle it in house?
I thought we all knew by now
molestations are handled out outside.
Right.
Like that just makes more sense.
That's interesting cause I didn't,
I always knew that they were accusing
people and they were expelling people and
they were judging people.
Whether whether or not it was based on
all the evidence or whether or not they
were correct in there,
assuming that this person was guilty.
Like this guy in the
University of Virginia,
he kinda got really fucked over
this and now he's suing and yeah,
but that's okay.
Let's say he was guilty.
Oh that's justice.
He got expelled for rape.
That's your fucking side.
Like how are you satisfied with that?
Yeah.
How could they be?
So you won't have a really good,
he'll have to go to
another different school.
Like what?
What have you done to stop
rape with that spelling people?
Well this is what I'm talking about
is getting my stories confused.
I'm talking about the
kid who the kid is suing.
Is the kid who the girl is
walking on my mattress girl.
Yeah,
he's suing.
He's suing for misandry.
That was,
I got confused.
The other,
the other story doesn't really have a
real man that was accused of anything,
right?
No,
the rolling stone when
you're talking about,
okay.
I have no fucking footnotes.
Sorry for any of this.
But uh,
what I read was this girl was part of the
Anti Rape Croup and she had a crush on
one of the guys in the Anti Rape Group.
Okay.
Because the friends of her were saying,
I don't know that we know something
happened because she was hysterical,
but she had been making up
this fake guy who was texting.
Yeah.
If this girl is really super cool,
she said at first this guy started out
as a guy to make the other boy thinks
someone wanted her.
Right.
And then it ended up with the guy that
you heard George Glass from the Brady
bunch basically she
made up a Georgia glass.
Right?
Like what's her name?
The Middle One?
I'm Brady Bunch Monaco.
No,
no,
Jan.
Yeah,
she did a Jan Brady and made this,
cause the older one,
her fake boyfriend.
So then she comes and says,
George Glass raped me and all that shit.
And it was,
it was to get attention from this guy.
She's like a weird chick
and she just got into it.
And so because they're inclined
to automatically believe,
they just,
they're like,
I don't know,
but it was bothering
them and the f the check,
they wrote it during them.
Yes.
And this is an anti rape group.
They were like,
I don't know if Jackie's
like telling the truth.
Oh,
okay.
Do you know what I mean?
But listen,
you got to look it up so I
promise you I didn't dream it.
Oh yeah.
But there's just more to,
I just don't want any
cut and dry everything.
Like if you,
if somebody says you got raped,
the answer is we'll
take it very seriously.
It's not believe or don't believe.
It's like,
well let's really investigate this because
that's an important thing to get to
the bottom of.
And there's got to be like really strong
punishment for someone who uses false
rape accusations.
I mean there,
there,
there has fucking been
there are there in place.
Well then we'll kind of punishment do
they did in the issue is let's say you
know that you had to say,
let's say you had,
you had to say you didn't get,
you know the numbers for a women who
lie about rape that are used usually by
feminist websites where they're like
only like 2% or something is of women.
That's a really bad number because that
that's counting women who have gone to
the police and recanted their accusation.
So you don't know if those women were
being pressured to do that or it does
that.
It's not an accurate measure of like a
liar is not going to go to that and say,
I was lying about it.
So not only your fucking real victims
and and also like a light more liars are
getting away with that says no.
Let's just look at what that,
what that is.
What I'm saying is two out
of a hundred if you look,
if you get 2% is two out of a
hundred that's not good odds.
Well the real nobody
knows is the real answer.
I'm just saying,
if you had a law to make it a really
stiff penalty for when we lie about rape,
I always watch it with that
because I don't want someone,
let's say a woman got
pressured into saying she lied.
It gets swept up under the,
uh,
under a law like that.
Do you know what I mean?
That's when it gets the death
penalty because I don't want,
one guy who didn't do it to try
to say is under their numbers.
If you have 20 guys and each one of
those guys had sex with five women,
two of them have been
falsely accused of rape.
That's crazy.
I'm not good at math,
but I believe you.
If that was great,
I'm not terrible at math to someone
probably about there screaming,
fuck.
But it is how the numbers work because
we're talking about a hundred people.
Okay?
If there's a hundred,
there's a hundred dudes or a hundred uh,
sexual,
uh,
cases,
right?
They're talking about 2%
2% of these rape cases are,
are falsely accused.
2% well,
Lizzy,
man,
I don't know.
I have to actually have a hundred rapes,
so I'm,
I'm really not doing it
right because like it's,
you'd have to have a hundred rapes.
It's not like a hundred people had a very,
had a 2% of sexual encounter.
Wow.
How good is the sweet?
I'm smoking.
It's very suspicious.
That calculates that much Joe.
This is what's wrong with my idea.
But even then,
okay,
let's say if there is a hundred cases
that are brought in front of the,
the cops,
right.
And out of a hundred of them,
two of them are totally bullshit.
That's a lot because they
probably get how many a year?
So how many a year or you're dealing with
where people are being falsely accused
and locked in a cage.
He's an as big of a deal as rape.
Of course.
Not.
Of course not.
Is it way worse than they're
getting falsely accused?
Probably way in the ones on
the penalty shapes than false.
Accused rapes.
Probably way more.
Right.
Well look,
so rape is up way bigger issue
than falsely accused rape.
But it doesn't mean that falsely
accusing someone of rape is okay.
It's not like Dell who says that
it's a real fucking problem.
Well they tried to underplay
it.
They try to make it out
like it's not a big deal.
The people that are really trying to
stop rape should be most concerned with
making sure that false rape
accusations are punished.
Because I make sure that you really
highlight like exactly what the actual
problem is.
The the real problem.
Not Wait.
When you say be most concerned with that,
I think be most concerned
with law enforcement of it.
You know,
but let me ask you this,
cause I always,
you know,
one in four that statistics
seemed very high,
right?
One in four,
four of low college age women are
raped because that wasn't the same.
But the is now.
Well now listen,
let me ask you,
cause I,
in my personal life,
I know a lot of people of both sexes,
Hoo Ha got sexually assaulted
somehow like a lot dude.
And you know,
probably that could be,
cause I just hung out
around drug people a lot.
You know,
that's how you meet people that got
fucking sexually assaulted or it could be
that the people that aren't in the bed
circle like that are just lying about it
and pretending that didn't happen to them.
So I don't know like it
maybe it is that high.
It's just there's no way to really tell.
Well,
it all depends on what you
consider sexual assault.
And they sometimes try to
make it as broad as possible.
Like one of the,
there's two really nutty robot Dick.
There's two really things that they,
uh,
they've tried to do recently.
One of them was in New Jersey.
They were trying to pass some law that
made it where if there's any deception
involved that lead to
someone having sex with you,
then it's rape.
I can't say I'm a big
time producer anymore.
Oh my God,
I can't tell what I'm
a foot doctor anymore.
You'll be a,
you become a rapist as long as if,
if that's the reason why the
person under false pretense early.
If the lie was,
I don't have aids,
then I get it.
But other than that,
yeah,
that's,
yeah.
But you know what it is,
man.
It's like everybody makes it
makes sex such a fucking big deal.
That's a real part of
the problem is that sex,
when everybody wants the idea of
pleasure between people and part of it is
because we don't wear any
clothes because we were close.
Rather we cover everything up.
And then the idea of like getting at it,
oh,
it's underneath there.
When they get some,
and we make it out to be
such a big deal and we,
we,
it becomes like this
overwhelming thing that like,
it sort of like infects
people's consciousness.
You know,
we're,
we're fascinated by all aspects of it.
Whether it's a,
whether it's rape or whether
it's abstinence or whether it's,
you know,
monogamy or whether it's being a whore.
It's like Wah,
we're just obsessed.
Obsessed with sex.
Yeah.
Well listen,
that doesn't have my girlfriend put it
reaps just like a very primal form of
dominance.
And that's what a what a Gal.
Yeah.
Then she's smart,
but that's what it is.
Like my dog,
my poor fucking dog got like,
that's an animal fucking thing.
That's in mammals,
man.
Yeah.
He said it really is.
It certainly is,
but do the only way I think
you're ever going to stop it.
The only way that really,
truly makes sense.
You've got to figure out how to
engineer better human beings.
Yeah.
Obviously only way.
It's the only way,
but how the fuck do you do that?
It is kind of good kitten.
Like hopefully I don't think there's a
people survive that it won't kind of get
more civilized hope.
I don't think so too.
As long as everything keeps going
and assuming it's not a fucking,
you know,
mad max thing.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
With the preppers win.
That's when I was in South Dakota,
the earth,
this guy,
I was doing this place in South Dakota,
this something beach club.
It was actually a good show,
but the dude that booked me,
or like the manager of the club,
he drove us to a mount
Rushmore and we were talking,
he was telling me that he's
building a bunker and I was like,
dude,
like don't you already like live in
a bunker called this South Dakota.
Right.
And he and I.
It's for Jesus reasons,
not red dawn reasons.
Jesus reasons.
So he thinks the second coming,
I mean we talk,
he's a real nice guy too.
We talk about real.
I've just,
I used to believe all that shit not,
this is the second comment by the
end times and Armageddon and I don't,
there's nowhere does it say you're going
to be able to have a bunker in fucking
like a bunker.
You're way out of it.
You can use the information
that God's provided you.
Make sure that your family would
be the only ones that survive.
Much like no it didn't see.
The Internet is like the,
the Voice of God really tells
you about the impending.
A return of kills.
Kills everyone was a surprise.
God wanted me to masturbate that much.
Oh,
you know it's fucked.
If you,
if the second coming he's coming,
that means Jesus is going to take you.
He's going to take you up to heaven.
He thinks maybe he won't.
He thinks he won't be taken maybe
and he thinks like he'll have to.
He's that bad that he had.
He'd probably have to hang
out and go to heaven later.
She's going to have to fuck these
people that he's gotten prisoned in his
bunker.
Yeah.
Duncan Trussell met one of those
dudes who went and visited a,
this,
this bomb shelter bunker thing under the,
under a mountain somewhere.
He drove deep into it.
We do this Scifi show where he drove deep.
They have RVs down in there and there
are supplies the rate and not like the
band.
Well,
if you believe the fucking Bible,
by the way it says not even the mountains.
We'll hide any people.
So they don't bother with your bunker.
Just a read your fucking,
but that guy was a prepper.
He wasn't oh Jesus.
Bang.
Oh well that's smarter.
You grew up.
Jehovah's Witnesses are,
the other ones are not
allowed to use doctors.
That's a Christian scientist.
I'm not even sure what extent
they're like that either.
But that's not Jehovah's Witnesses.
No.
So what is the Jehovah's Witnesses?
The ones that knock on everybody doors.
And what,
what was that,
the main door knocker it was just fucking,
uh,
you grew up in,
it's a religion where,
yeah,
yeah.
You have to like do it.
So it's not like being like,
I would always envy Catholics cause
you don't have to fucking do it.
Right.
They had like a cool,
like,
like I had to like be in it,
you know,
all the time.
Yeah.
That's your primary goal
is to be ready for the end.
Most people that call themselves
Catholic fucking never go to church.
Probably a big percentage
kick out Michael Corleone.
Right.
Ever.
Like you're a murderer,
you have to leave.
Jesus forgives you.
He just kind of go to confession,
talk about all those
people that you don't look,
it's a good system.
So you have a hand job and once
in a while for that and for,
did your parents grow up in it?
Uh,
no.
My mom converted from Catholic
when she was a teenager and my dad,
my grandfather converted his family.
My Dad's home.
He told my dad was like 12th.
Wow.
Your grandfather.
So the grandfather took the
father and the whole family,
including your dad when he
was already 12 years old.
And so yeah,
come on,
you're coming with me.
But my joining the call.
Yeah.
Well my dad grew up really like
definitely build planes for World War II.
Wow.
He was a fucking smart dude.
So he was an engineer,
but he never went to college and uh,
he was very anti war I guess or
something at the end of the war.
And he was like a would
you have as witnesses?
Don't get involved in politics or a war,
but you can't be a
Christian and fight a war.
I don't know why people think he can,
but you can't.
It's pretty clear about it.
People really believe God gives
a fuck about their country.
And it's,
it's so like in plain English.
Well,
I mean it's an Aramaic,
but it's like,
it's a very clear teaching that he
doesn't approve of any of the countries.
He's going to ruin all of them.
You just have to obey
them until the income.
That's,
that's the extent of your obligation.
But a,
you can't fight like drop a bomb
and another Christian for America.
How could that fucking go over?
Yeah.
And if America was dropping bombs
like Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
they had out of a couple
of Christians down there,
of course they had to.
You think God forgives you for that?
Like what?
More than a cause you've saved whatever.
Like he doesn't give a
shit about your country.
So how did you bail on it?
I,
uh,
I started reading,
well,
first of all I was like an asshole.
I was just like,
didn't want to do it,
you know,
I had that in me of what
kind of school did you go to?
Uh,
I went to regular school.
I wasn't like homeschooled.
Some people do that in it.
Right.
But you know,
I went to my and shit,
you know.
Okay.
So it wasn't that super
restrictive for me.
So it depends on your parents were,
was it you going to school
and talking to other kids,
it's sorted.
You lead you off the path of God no more.
It was a,
I went to college,
uh,
postal I went to,
it was,
yeah,
but I know that the seeds I already been
reading like kind of skeptic shit on my
lunch breaks at the Wiz.
I would buy these magazines at Barnes
and noble that would call skeptic.
So that feels like a
little foundation of it.
And then pussy later
when I got to college.
Wow.
Yeah.
Pussy right out of that.
So both things are good.
The reading was good,
and then the pussy was good.
But what is it like being like 1920 going,
what the fuck did I think?
Oh,
I felt really guilty,
dude.
Do you mean that's one of the reasons
why you probably did friends with Ari?
Yeah,
I got along with him immediately.
You guys have these exact same story.
Yeah.
While I was like a minute,
I mean,
I was technically a minister and uh,
and he was supposed to be like a ramp.
I right.
She had already lived in one of those
crazy religious houses in Israel for a
long time and was so many years studying.
I don't remember.
He talks.
I don't always listen,
but
I just don't remember.
He mumbles a lot.
It's hard to catch everything.
You've got to go,
wait what?
You lived in a what?
Say That again coach,
what does that word but um,
you know,
he was studying the tour
like 10 hours a day.
Like all day they would still be on tour
and he was full Gung Ho and then you
know,
by the time when I met him it was
only like a few years after this,
which is really crazy now that I look
back and think about it like he was not,
when he was coming first coming
around to the comedy store,
he was not that far removed from
living in this crazy religious commune.
And you know,
I'll tell you a nine
types of the problems,
especially with this rape shit,
all of this horrible stuff about how to
direct him to just treat it is straight
out of the good book.
I mean that's like a huge,
the Moses story had dyno.
Did you have a study Bible
shoot when you're younger?
I only studied it in first grade.
First grade was the only year
that I went to Catholic school.
And then second grade I won second grade,
I went to San Francisco.
So it was first grade.
And then second grade was like super
hippie people living next door,
like a,
went from one extreme to a
total Sodom and Gomorrah.
Right.
So I don't remember any
of the biblical stories.
I looked him up as an adult.
I had my book of Bible Stories,
which I look back at it.
The lessons are hilarious
that were in there.
So like Abraham's daughter,
Dinah or maybe Dina,
I don't know how to pronounce these names,
but,
uh,
she was,
she made friends with like worldly girls,
you know,
from the city that
weren't her same religion.
Right.
And she'd go hang out in the
city and then this guy check him,
saw her and forced her
to lie down with him.
Like she,
you know,
she got raped,
but who you might've held their hand.
It's like ancient fucking,
you know,
bronze age,
Jewish shy.
So it might've held her hand.
So then he falls in love
up in a micro aggression.
He fully,
yeah,
he falls in love with
her after he raped her,
aren't,
goes to Abraham and says,
let me marry her,
you know,
which will preserve her honor.
He really was like,
okay,
fine.
Uh,
but your whole household has
to get circumcised first one.
The COMERICA is fine,
we'll all get our Dick Smith.
Okay.
So while while they get are recovering
from getting their dicks snipped,
Dina's brothers are enraged by this.
Like it was their sister a whore and
they go and kill everyone in check hims
household,
like his whole family while they're laid
up from their Dick's getting cut and
then Abraham Psych,
what did you just do to us?
Now people are going to
hate us around the world.
It's like one of those things about
how Jews are going to be in trouble now
because something you did and he goes,
now people will be hated wherever we
go because of this thing you have done.
And uh,
yeah.
So the,
the lesson that you get from it
and my book of Bible Stories,
like all of this happened because DNA
chose poor associates and they put it all
on their own.
That's the lesson of the story.
This dumb bitch to stay home.
So that's getting out
of the fucking Bible.
And so listen,
that's why Patriot,
I always see like patriarchy.
I'm against that shit too.
Like that,
that ancient Bible,
he patriarchy shit,
I'm not for that.
I'm,
I'm Kinda like w would be 90% with a lot
of these shit if they didn't have such
a thought crimes unit.
Exactly.
That's the thing about this whole
social social justice movement
is that in looking for people that have,
that have been guilty
of these transgressions,
they,
they've missed a lot of
allies to miss people.
Like they're on their side,
like you like being like a lot of money
and they're trying to make assholes out
of people and they're doing it.
The vast majority of the people that are
involved in this like really aggressive
social justice warrior shit,
they're fucking depressed,
man.
They're really depressed people.
You'll go through their timeline.
It's almost without fail.
When I read some really ridiculous over
the top hyper aggressive social justice
where shit,
I'll go to the fucking pro,
their Twitter profile and
I'll find some depressed shit.
Right.
I'll find some tweets about depression.
I was find some tweets about,
you know,
how,
everything sucks today.
Like I see what's going on.
You're,
yeah.
You're lashing out at the world
through a legitimate cause.
Well,
don't take it personal thing.
Exactly.
Say like,
I'm every woman.
No,
you're not.
Let's see if you can find enough of
those people and you get together,
then you feel like you are right because
you're around a bunch of other fuck
heads that are also
being that Catholic guy.
What's his name?
Michael Donahue.
It's just him and like
his cousin or something.
Right.
Or the,
our league,
like it doesn't take that much,
but it used to be member.
It was church crazies that
would write these letters.
Yeah.
Like please take something off
the air and now it's fucking a,
it's like young college kids.
That's insane.
Well,
it's,
yeah,
they literally is taking the
exact same position that,
that fucking Michael,
whatever the fuck his name guy is.
I've heard that guy talk on opiate
Anthony before the Catholic league.
Oh yeah,
I've heard that guy talking to opie
and Anthony and defend because how
Catholicism,
it was like,
what are you talking about?
Like how,
what do you use it?
You're,
you're mad at someone
making fun of Catholicism.
It's one of the most easily
made fun of religions of all.
I asked him this on that show.
I'm like,
cause I was a Christian.
Like you know,
you're supposed to rejoice
when you are persecuted.
Right.
That's what Christ said.
They're going to persecute you.
Like they did me.
So rejoice.
So you're supposed to be happy about it
because it means you're doing the right
thing and that's,
you're not supposed to go,
oh dear,
you're a Christian.
Cause she's turning the other cheek.
You don't fucking,
what did he say to that?
He just kind of ignored it.
I don't think it's about that for him.
I think it's about publicity.
It's,
yeah,
it's publicity and being part of a club.
It's just all football
team shit everybody does.
And endorsements.
I mean,
cause they really getting paid a lot
of money by other Catholics who want to
support Catholicism.
I have a friend who's a Catholic and
he's got a lot of money and he's fucking
craziest shit.
And he has a priest come over his house.
When he buys a new house,
a priest comes over and
does like a fucking little
seance and shit or something.
I mean they,
they have some sort of a,
they have some sort of a call to say
what the fuck they call it's Voodoo.
It's all Voodoo.
Real Catholic gives 10%
of his money to church.
It's like the whole thing.
Yeah.
When they,
they,
they have him involved in all sorts of
church projects and they're just sucking
money out of this dude.
It's,
it's a God damn call.
It's 100% called,
well,
I,
here's how I judge him.
All the religions is,
uh,
how much does it cost?
Okay,
yeah,
I know.
And then
do what,
does God do his own killing or
do I have to do his killing?
And,
uh,
and then my personal thing is if I have
to stay in it more for my mom or my dad,
like my religion,
my mom was the reason I had to
stay for a while more than my dad.
But if I was from like a harsher place,
it would be like your father's honor.
You can't leave cause you,
that's like a more primitive,
that's how,
you know,
it's kind of primitive.
But if it doesn't cost that much,
then fine.
And if I'm not,
there's no violence.
Once you take the violence part out of it,
like nationalism or a whatever,
it's a lot less threatening.
You know,
it's a,
it's more voluntary now.
The kind of shitty thing is that they
will stop talking to you if you leave.
Right.
So you have to face,
you know,
being shunned or some,
I was just fellowshipped.
Right.
So that means like a lot of my former
friends can't talk to me or they would be
in trouble for talking to an apostate.
So that's fellow shipped
disfellowshipped disfellowship yeah.
It's like a disconnection
in a Scientology.
Wow.
Except it's not as harsh as a,
you know,
like I still speak to my mom,
like it's not like she mad at you.
No,
no,
not now.
She was mad initially.
Does she ever listen to reason
that it might be horseshit?
Yeah,
but I don't want to fucking
talk her out of her shit really.
First of all that that charges taken up
a lot of slack of hanging out with my
mom and they said to him,
okay,
God bless them.
I want you to lose that
where I got to pick up.
I say,
I don't want to have
those calls from rice.
Yeah,
get it saves you some $2 bills.
Like Weirdo mom,
Shit.
She called me up that she tell me she
had a hotel and it was going to send me
and my girlfriend,
uh,
they had these jelly beans and a bowl,
which is like,
what's your address?
I'm gonna send you some jelly beans from
his fucking bowl in the hotel lobby.
That's hilarious.
So you bailed,
you can't talk to them anymore.
And what was the process?
Did you have to fill out
paperwork or do you say,
oh,
I just stop going,
but I think my mom wanted
me to write a letter.
I'm like,
I don't owe any shame in a letter
to the chair's resignation.
Wow.
I'm like,
I don't owe that.
I put in my time would be important.
I'd fucking church.
I don't owe them a letter.
How old?
You'll notice I'm going.
How old were you when you wrapped it up?
19 wow.
Oh no wait,
maybe I was a 20 that's
a good time though.
That 1920 times.
It's just becoming a man basically
becoming a man like you're on.
The more you're at the door,
21 know like official is
Chi declawed you know,
before I had to go live in the world.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
they teach you to not be worldly.
That's what you're learning to be.
And how so like would be
as Babes unto the world.
Like a Paul said,
you have to be,
you know,
like when you see people
that just came out of a cult,
there's a certain kind
of innocence to them.
So when I came out it was always like
these kind of real slutty girls that would
fuck me.
Like it really experienced girls and
that was my appeal to them was kind of my
fucking foster kid.
Sean,
you know that makes sense.
Like I was with a lot of like kind either
like a stripper or like some kind of
sex work or where we were like
foster kids together kind of on it.
Do you know what I mean?
Like you took care of each other
because like you treat me like not,
not a John.
They treat me like the like the Weird
James James Woods from casino that for
some reason they can never
get away from this loser.
Oh that's right.
So the guy didn't,
yeah,
I didn't make any money
for the whole fucking,
I just had to have girlfriends that
I had to just like live off of.
So this is not good.
It's this,
when you first got out of the church?
When I first gear,
I got the name.
When did you start doing
standup in college.
So you went from the church to live in,
in New York with chauffeurs
first I was in Philly.
Okay.
No might,
well my girlfriend at the time in college,
but she's a,
when I met her and then she
became like a comic and then uh,
but I was with her for like,
he's going to be like six years,
but we were engaged but
I didn't have a job like,
and I like refuse to get
a job the whole time.
I was just a piece of shade.
Said,
yeah.
Wow.
Tell me I'm a colonic.
Well you just said you were a comic.
That's it.
Yeah.
Here's a deep been doing it then.
Not enough to do any of that
a year or two years from now.
Like me,
like three or four years before,
but just weren't making any money yet.
And then a,
and then I ended up with this girl who
was older than me and may kind of good
money and she liked it better
when I didn't have money.
When I started to get
one more shit at that,
put a strain because she
could suddenly upset.
Yeah.
She didn't want me to be out
of that kind of control zone.
Yeah.
I dated a girl once and uh,
we broke up and she,
she dated this guy and she was very
specific about why she was with him and I
go,
why?
She goes,
she's never going to
fucking break up with me.
And I was like,
really?
She goes,
yeah,
I mean he's great.
All I like them but I'm
better looking than he has.
I like,
she was like really adamant about me.
Advance.
You engineered the control position.
Yeah.
Relationship.
You're tired of not being in control and
relationships tying them into even you
or what have you and you're like,
this is it.
But she would get drunk and
wanna fuck all her ex boyfriends.
She was just a mad maniac,
which is always how that goes.
It's like people,
like one thing about my girlfriend now,
like I really,
it kind of up to my fucking who I am a
little bit because now I would never be
in another bullshit like
psycho relationship.
Like I'm just not going
to settle for that.
I'll be fucking alone.
I don't give a shit like,
so that kind of taught me to,
because I met somebody that like,
I really got along with
that I thought was like,
you know,
like I don't know,
just got me.
So I was like,
oh,
I don't have to be in these things anymore
because I am so low self esteem that
I'm like,
well this person wants to
fuck me and Lou stay with me.
Stay with them.
It becomes a one of those things where
sometimes you don't even know who you are
if you're in a bad relationship.
Yes.
Cause the way you're
reacting to this person,
that's what makes you
different fucking person.
Yeah.
If you're in a good relationship
and you realize like,
Oh wow,
these are possible,
but until you get in one line,
so some people go through their entire
life birth to death without hitting gold.
They chip away at that.
Fuck you deep digging into
another Chiba part of you're
a bold man while had a quarter.
Very,
very bold man.
That's pretty good.
Now why do you feel sad
when you go back home?
Home to where my mom's Hell
No.
Back home to New York where
you don't have to chant,
get your weed that easy.
Oh my God dude.
Ari Shaffir it tells
me it was a nightmare.
I think God or he sometimes has something.
I wish I could get shit like this there.
Yeah.
Is that like hide like
an animal to smoke weed?
Yeah,
you do have to hide like an animal right
to in Seattle I was smoking in front of
a cop at this ridiculous glass,
like a wizard pipe.
A good day officer.
It was so relaxing.
It was a pipe you would
never bring outside.
I wonder when that's going to be the
entire country cause like in New Orleans
apparently you could just drink on
the street and we had a driver in New
Orleans.
He was telling me once he
was outside of New Orleans,
he was doing something and he's talking
to the cop and the cop was asking them a
question and he had a beer in his hand
and he was just talking to the cop and he
didn't realize the cop was talking to
him because he had a beer in his hand.
Oh.
So he finishes the beer and then
he cracks open a second one.
The cop goes,
are you fucking retarded?
Like what do you do?
And then the cop goes,
where are you from?
And he goes,
New Orleans.
And he's like,
oh,
okay,
listen dude,
you can't do that shit in other places.
Like this is the only place where you
can do what else happened to this?
Definitely white man.
Nothing,
not even a slap on the wrist.
They told him to put his
beer back in the back,
asked him to cool it a little bit.
But you get used to that and you know if
you did what you did in Seattle in some
parts of the country,
they would fuck you over man.
They would do would put you in a
cage if you were in parts of Georgia.
They'll find out they're
not cool about it.
And Georgia,
is there any places that
have open container laws?
Because I remember
growing up there was like,
people were like,
oh,
you're allowed to drink
if you're not driving.
Like you could have it
like in the back seat.
And then I went to another place and did
that and got in trouble for having an
open container and they're like,
no,
you can't do that.
Yeah,
there's,
well they used to,
it used to be okay everywhere that people
used to like literally have a beer in
their lap and they drove around and
suddenly people were crashed into each
other.
They go,
okay,
you can't have a fucking got it
took to fix that to put it together.
Those normal shit,
man,
I can't drink while I'm driving.
Yeah.
That was literally,
that was normal shit a long time
ago and like seventies right.
That changed in like the 70s I don't know.
When they started incorporating
drunk driving laws and I don't know,
it was a bunch of people got killed and
they didn't really have a strong and
saying,
I don't know why.
I don't know when,
oh,
when,
and I wonder what they did.
At first,
I guess it was just testing your
movement and then they figured out
breathalyzers and then the,
you know,
moved on from there.
But yeah,
no,
I don't want to,
I can't stand fucking drunk.
I just so annoying to deal with like,
cause I don't really drink that much dude.
I'm more of just like a pine.
Yeah.
Drunk is the worst as far as like people,
I mean potheads can
absolutely be annoying,
but the sure they're not as
violent and true and retarded.
That's the,
that's the big one.
The standing real close
to God when you are,
when you're out somewhere and a drunk
person just interrupts a conversation,
just gets in your face,
starts striking at you and you're like,
oh God.
Yeah.
And if you try to avoid them,
you're the asshole.
Yeah.
I'm telling you,
I just,
my lease a worst drug.
It's the worst drug.
It's one of the worst drugs,
but it's fine if you can manage it,
if you can handle it correctly.
I mean get an eight ball at least,
and even out like a gentleman,
like a gentlemen,
get an eight ball and either
you're going to get that drunk,
at least a,
you know,
can even out like a gentleman named
herself up by your bootstraps with,
I have a buddy used to do a lot of coke
and he used to always drink forties
after he did coke and
smoke it and then he would,
he would like his heart and be like,
oh,
nice to have to take him to the liquor
store and he'd buy like old English.
You remember those bags of you get
a fucking 40 ounce of old English.
Yeah.
You ever try that stuff?
It's unbelievably strong.
Yeah.
It's,
they call it malt liquor
because it's not really beer.
Right?
Is that the idea?
I don't know.
Is that what it is?
I think it is beer,
but I think it's just made different.
It's made a stronger,
stronger.
Okay.
How,
what do you think the
alcohol by volume is?
I'm like,
liquor.
Well,
what,
what is,
what is a bug like a
Budweiser likes a s seven.
I have no idea.
Well,
it's different in America than
it is in Canada and Canada.
It's like 9% mostly of us.
It's like 7% but a,
what percentage is malt liquor?
Did you hear what happens when you
ask Siri what zero divided by zero is?
No,
no.
What happens Siri,
what's zero divided by zero?
Imagine that you have zero cookies and
you split them evenly among zero friends.
How many cookies does each person get?
See it doesn't make sense.
And cookie monster is sad that there
are no cookies and you are sad that you
have no friends.
That's real series a card.
Such a mean bitch.
Um,
the term includes any alcoholic beverage
of the 5% or more alcohol by volume
made with malted barley.
So it's just another way of saying beer,
I guess.
Yeah,
he's still like drink mad dog.
20,
I think it's called.
And then,
yeah,
drink.
I had 'em mad dog 20.
We had that an old English.
We're drinking those.
I've watched a,
you ever see that movie?
Superfly oh yeah.
Back in the day,
me and my friend John,
we,
uh,
when we're just starting out as comics,
we got hammered on old
English and mad dog 20,
20,
and those 40 ounce liquors
and watch superfly.
I remember being like
shocked at how strong it was.
Like,
I don't know how much the old English has.
Let's see.
Let's find out.
How much does it,
how much would you think old English as,
um,
let's go at 8%.
Eight.
Yeah,
I bet it's around that.
What proof is that?
What is it?
That's it.
Steel Reserve.
Mickey's.
Oh yeah.
I used to drink that Mickey's lot still
steel reserve is the motherfucker that's
8% that's,
hmm.
All right.
Um,
what else?
What else is fucked up?
Saint Ides?
That's eight 20 natty Daddy.
He had that bud light line Margarita.
No.
What's that?
It's pretty good.
Cobra is only six,
Huh?
Heartburn.
To me,
I would've thought King Cobra
would be off the charts.
What does King Cobra,
Cobra King Cobras.
A malt liquor.
It's not what's,
what's the six?
Oh yeah.
I would've thought it'd be more too.
Yeah.
So it was thought it
would have fucked you up.
Is that just because the advertising
was done with that black guy from star
wars?
I remember Billy Dee Williams.
Why is that cool?
No,
he was cold.
45 oh he was totally fine.
How much does it cost?
45 have cool.
45 gravity logger.
Five six what does 10 evil eyes?
10 Jesus Christ and camp black ice.
Black ice.
Okay.
I'm all,
I thought it's a camp.
What the fuck dude?
12 wow.
Stack high gravity lager.
His head 12 oh my God.
We should get some of that
and have a drunk cast.
We need to get some of that stack.
High gravity logger.
Jamie,
you need to go to Compton and find out
what it Salamat cause they don't sell
that in white neighborhoods.
Need to go,
go do some research for the show.
It's very important robot Dick.
I know every,
I can't help it.
You smell cigarettes also or do you
know you give up what's per weight or
nicotine level is a six six yeah.
That's better.
That is sex.
I don't wake up,
you know,
you have a unique perspective coming
from a really crazy religious background
like that as a comic cause he,
cause he kind of see where the pitfalls
of thinking live because you were
indoctrinated in them from I
have a strong reaction to them.
Something like really bugs
me if I encounter it again.
Well it's what,
that's one of the things that you and I,
you got to you and I share this opinion
of like a lot of what's going on,
like what people would like to
call social justice warriors.
That it is really like
kind of a religious thing.
It's a same,
it's a very similar thing.
It's not an even objective approach that
a lot of people are taking this thing.
It's as gang mentality pylon.
I'll take on faith with it that I'm
not just going to take on faith.
Okay.
It's really just the bottom line.
But uh,
you know,
whenever I got to taking things on faith,
I don't worry is bad.
I don't mind.
Like if it's a little more
challenge to get my jokes over,
like I just makes me better.
So I don't have a
problem with that at all.
I like trying to,
trying to get around that.
I think that makes it funnier,
but don't then make it like I
can't work if I fuck up in the,
in,
in the cause of trying to do that.
Right,
right.
Well I think that like a gangster
movie is a legitimate art form.
You know,
the soprano's is a legitimate art form.
Right?
Well guess what someone doing?
Obviously tongue in cheek misogynist
material is a legitimate art form as well.
Like you can't say the dice clay is
not a legitimate artist thing of people
couldn't,
they just didn't know it was a character.
Like it wasn't all,
you think a lot of that
shit of against him was,
people didn't realize he
was doing a character.
Of course they realized it.
They were just looking to be upset.
It cause as a kid I was a kid when he's
out and I remember not knowing that that
was a character.
Well you were a kid though,
right?
If you're old enough to pay taxes,
you should no dice Clay's fucking around.
I think people like don't.
Yeah.
It's a fucking,
I think he's a,
he's a great artist.
Nora Dunn,
where she was like,
you know,
I think she's about to be off the show.
So she did that stunt of not coming on
and the rest of the cast was mad at her
like,
so what are we the woman haters
cause we did the show with those.
That's right.
Because the types of
things that fucked him up,
whatever movie's Great.
Ford Fairlane I love that movie.
What fucked him up was there
was no internet back then.
That's what fucked him up.
When you get banned from MTV,
like he did like [inaudible] recourse.
There's nothing to do.
Oh you're right.
He could have been on the fucking NBA.
Well they can blackball you.
They could back then.
They can't really blackball
you anymore because you go,
all right,
I'm starting to dice clay podcast.
Oh Mike,
I liked to,
he has an album of him bombing.
Oh,
it's one of the best and that it's
Rick Ruben fucking produced it.
The laughter die I use,
I got a very interesting
thing that I have never,
what does it,
comic has a,
it's a two disc set.
It's just two discs.
It's great.
It's an awful though.
He's bombing.
This guy gets up in the
middle of his set and he goes,
you're about it.
Funny as our glass on milk
guys.
Cause he wasn't announced and
he showed up a danger fields,
which is,
you know,
the dingy,
his little clubs in New York,
so it's like we're count
Chocula was buried.
That club doesn't make any sense because
it's named after one of the all time
great standup comedians and it's always
filled with hacks and it's empty most of
the time.
But there's was a few
great comics at work.
They're like George.
I did set there with auto
and George during the prom
season when they rotate the
people in one after the other,
after the other.
So it was always a few comics,
but there was also a few that were
hanging around there that didn't work
anywhere else.
They just,
it's like,
it was like the comedy store in
the 90s when the comedy had these,
the comedy store had these like ancient,
I remember that.
I remember like the very
last of them remember Nancy?
A fuck.
She was a host there.
She was nice.
She had a boat telling me what the
hell was her name was Nancy something?
I know she was like a holdover
from the old that of that crew.
Yeah,
exactly.
She told me how to get like
health insurance if you couldn't,
didn't,
you know.
Oh Wow.
Did you ever meet Bobby?
Bobby gone by the time you got there.
Who's,
hey Bobby was the big Scottish guy.
That was a doorman.
No,
Chartio is there.
Oh,
okay.
All the way by the way is no,
like,
you know the county comes
of like hot wagers is,
it was just all old men,
like a fucking steakhouse Tuxedos.
Tuxedos on.
Yeah.
And that's how Bobby wasn't,
Bobby was this giant power
lifter and needs to have a,
he didn't have to have
like some ridiculous scene.
You know,
they would have to like tailor
his shit because he was a,
he was a mountain of a man.
He was only about five to eight,
but he's probably about 230 pounds.
He was fucking enormous,
just spit fucking tank of a guy.
And he would literally grab people
by their neck and pick them up,
like lift them up and carrying him out.
So I'm do it.
He just grabbed this guy
and carried him out to,
he was funnier than any of the
comedians who was hilarious.
And it was right before you go onstage.
It was,
I guess you're going to go try
the trick them at that bag.
I Shite active yours and they're like,
you,
you would kill.
And he goes,
look at that yet.
Tricked another group of assholes.
But he was funny,
he was saying,
right,
right.
He was fucking with you.
But he was funny and he knew who was
good and it was bad and he wasn't shy and
letting you know.
Yeah.
He's a funny dude,
man.
Worked at club for a long ass time.
Do you go there and do
you do spots until uh,
you know,
I was like mad and he was like
vowed I would never go back there.
Why?
And I think they even forgot.
I told them never call me because
they've just called me like,
are you around for where?
It's like that's how
much it didn't matter.
My little stand.
What was the stand over?
I can't remember to do some shit.
Where the fuck I don't remember.
But I was like furious about it.
I can't,
I can't remember.
That's a club that should be
revived if it's still around God,
you got to make sure that
place doesn't go under.
That's a magic room.
The way that room is set up and built.
Yeah.
I used to like playing there and it was
good to get a half hour spot somewhere,
you know,
crate Rome.
It's a great room.
It's just,
it was always just manage
a very bizarre way.
Yeah,
I do.
Uh,
so iconic I guess.
I mostly like the stand and like,
so it's supposed to be
amazing standing here.
A lot of great things about it.
I fucking love it.
And the seller and then stand up New York.
I'm out a lot,
you know,
danger fields was where they,
they did an actual danger special
from that place I think it was.
No.
Yeah,
I know,
right?
Yeah.
God Damn.
What a club.
That's funny.
That was like one of the early
specialist that was in a comedy club,
you know,
instead of a big giant theater
and is one of the best ones too.
Yeah.
That's a classic one.
Live walk.
Yeah.
That's a real classic one.
Did you ever get a chance to
hear Rodney Dangerfield perform?
I've been telling you about there.
Have you seen any like
the old time grades?
Have you ever seen any of them wanting me?
I've watched Rodney doing his stand up.
I mean you meet in person,
right?
See Carlin at all?
Yeah.
Never in person.
Ever in person.
I was fucking missed a Rickles too.
Last time I was in Montreal.
I want to go see wrinkles.
He's still performing.
Huh?
I overeat.
Yeah.
I,
I had asked to be on too many shows.
I'm never doing that again.
Montreal.
Yeah.
Cause I wanted to go see some other shit.
I keep thinking I want to do spots,
you know,
and then I just have too
many and it's not as fine.
Well,
if you have a lot in a
nice place like Montreal,
you're not going to get
to explore the city too.
That's a,
that's a whole nother world.
That city.
I like it.
Damn man.
The summer.
It's great.
Love it there.
It's a whole nother world though.
I mean that is a French
speaking international city
that is just above main,
like it doesn't make any god damn sense
because Maine is like desolate waste
land and trees.
Dudes with coonskin hat,
you know,
looking at you from behind a
fucking Bush is why I got from,
you're not from around here with
your buddy in the Stephen King books,
you know that's all based on Maine.
Yeah.
They've inspired more horror,
horror stories with their
faces than any other people.
I've never been in a place where you
make fun of the state and people go more
fucking angry.
Oh,
you get may get furious.
They call the maniacs that they're,
they're maniacs.
Strongest suite I've ever had.
I gotten made from some Hick was
dude fuck God damn challenge dude.
And I,
if I could ever find it again,
it was like a dense fucking bud that
almost smelled like a car freshener.
It wasn't like delicious.
We'd smell really and it was so fucking
strong and we were not prepared for how
strong it was at all.
I couldn't book,
I like to smoke it again cause
I have a different palette now,
but we were all like out
of our minds and his weed.
Well couldn't you think that if
you were a dude living in some,
in the middle of nowhere
town and a place like Maine,
you could be like some crazy hacker guy
who makes his own computers and designs
his own drones and shit like that.
You could see some mad scientist dude
living by himself like that out there.
Right,
right.
Well couldn't you see a mad botness too?
Yeah,
I could totally see that as well until
they see some crazy fuck that's out there
and oppression.
It was some white wild ass,
you know,
they,
he planted it in the woods
with traps around it,
kind of weed.
You know,
that's how they do.
They,
they go out in the woods and make
their little stet grows and uh,
but we travel.
But yeah,
that makes sense.
But it also makes sense that
like someone in this day and age,
it's about how long ago was it?
You got this weed,
she didn't want to to go
over 10 years ago at least.
Well,
since 1994 they've had medical marijuana
in California I think was in 94 does
that past.
So from then on Shit's
been pretty commensurate.
I mean,
I don't think it's gotten much stronger.
I had some weed in the
late nineties it was just,
I've,
I've had weeds.
It's just as strong as
shit you're getting today.
So if some guy got it to him,
you know,
2005 somebody got it to him all the
way up in Maine just starts growing it.
That's totally feasible.
Or you know,
you're out.
Well you just sprayed it with
like bug spray or something?
I don't think so.
Just pissed on it.
His drink eats a lot of vitamins.
The vitamin PICE,
I eat my fighter shot today.
That's what my point was like.
That's a very loosely populated state,
you know,
and there's a couple cool cities,
like Bangor is a cool city
and Portland's a cool city,
but you go north of that and
there was virtually nothing.
They just really,
really small towns of beat people
barely eking by north of that is this
incredible fucking city.
It's nuts.
I'm saying just keep going.
So you
get past the wildlings and
you get to the front desk.
You got to climb the fence.
So weird that you guys are
talking about Portland.
I'm actually planning all
these places right now.
You'd probably talk about Portland,
Oregon.
I'm talking about Portland,
Maine,
Portland,
Somerville,
Massachusetts,
Somerville.
Yeah.
And Rhode Island.
Savo rod is stolen during
the common connection.
That's a great spot.
I used to do that.
It's adult,
a bank vault.
That's what it,
if it's the same location,
it used to be literally a bank fault.
The green room for a
comedian was the vault.
The place was a bang.
Wow.
But it was terrible.
Like the one thing about it that was
terrible was that you had these giant
ceilings cause it was like a bank.
Oh right.
And you're,
but you were on stage in a bank.
I mean it used to be a bank and
it's like a bank parking lot.
I got the worst food poisoning
my life in that place.
Like in the year two,
not even 99 or something like that.
I don't even know what year it was.
You eat that poisoned you a pizza.
You know when you eat Sushi
and he'd get a poisoning,
it's usually not the fish because
they have to freeze the fish first.
That's usually the rice that
rice is like people's hands.
Yeah.
They say that about a salad.
The salad is one of the worst things
that people get food poisoning from.
Imagine that.
Trying to be all healthy.
Like I don't want to use toxic meat.
I'll sit here and eat my
micro been festival lettuce.
But,
um,
Montreal,
if you go,
like,
if it's counterintuitive
because if you are like,
if you were headed north and you,
you know,
you went all through New
York and Massachusetts and
you got up to me and he'd be
like,
okay,
we've got to turn around.
There's nothing up here cause nothing.
But if you just kept going
be like,
Whoa,
this is better than Boston.
This is a magical city.
This is beautiful.
Everybody taught there
are different languages.
Not better than Boston,
but it's,
it's similar.
Yeah,
I love it there.
No,
Montreal's a shit.
Toronto's a shit too.
You have a good time to Toronto to yeah,
it's like a big city but they're nice,
weird.
The crowds are good.
I can see I Canadian like kind
of Pc people are different
cause you know what it
is.
They'll hear you out.
All my jokes are overly wordy too,
so you've got to like hear me out before
you get mad or it's not going to work.
But they're Canadian.
So their attention span
is just like longer.
And when I fuck up here,
it's because somebody was half listening
and just heard a word and didn't know
what I was saying.
Outrage,
attack dude.
I got a girl dumped a
drink on me at the seller.
Why?
I can say this is all my hour and a
white precious children of gay marriage.
Archie hour.
She,
no,
no this but it's on my hour.
If he was on my own.
But she goes,
she comes is the beginning of the thing.
I asked if there are for gay marriage
and I go cause I'm against it.
That's why I brought it up
and this is the first line,
right.
But if you listen to the joke,
it's clearly a pro gay marriage show,
but she just ran up,
grabbed some other guys drink.
It wasn't her drink.
She picked up a dude's strength in
front of her and doused me with it.
And then they're starting to pull her out.
I'm like,
Whoa,
what just why did you do that?
And she's like,
you're against gay marriage.
Is that crate?
I like,
first of all,
the joke was pro that
and then also was a joke.
It's about like,
why we can't have it
here because you know,
we have a constitution
God gave us and like,
Oh,
you know,
we lose protection.
Like he watches your holes,
you know?
Right.
Like a diamond loop
and see what they're up to.
Look at that.
More protection for you.
Um,
so what did she say?
Cause I'm against gay marriage.
But did you explain to her that you
were going and this is a satire?
No,
they'll bounce her,
threw her out.
I was trying to make her
stay actually so I could,
it was so shocking that it happened.
I wasn't like mad,
but that's exactly what
we're talking about.
We're talking about people
that have a black or white.
There's a,
you know,
there's a,
yeah,
I'm not proud of you.
That's why we all supposedly hated
George W for his moral certitude.
So I don't want to hear yours.
Especially not in satire,
especially not when you're
going to see a comedy show.
I'm above the law is how I,
my attitude towards comedy,
whatever the fucking a social norm is,
I'm above that.
That's why I took this job.
I took this job to not do what you do.
I don't work at your fucking office,
so I'll have to clean it up
like we're at the office.
Do you want me,
people think that that's the way you're
supposed to think and talk all the time.
Because they all think
they're comics to that.
Jon Stewart said that,
that like,
you know,
people would play music that's
magical to people and painting.
That's magic.
But everyone thinks they're a comedian.
They all think they are.
So that's why they feel
qualified to tell you.
Well,
because they talk,
right?
You don't see it as being much different.
You're talking and they're talking.
Oh,
people used to say about stern.
They'd be like,
oh,
I could do I.
Which stores do you just
go talk about bossy?
You know,
like that attitude.
That's what they think it is.
So when they talk about mean jokes,
they're not thinking of someone
crafting something clever.
They think of,
Oh,
you're a lesbian,
like in their head.
That's the same as a joke.
We don't even agree on what jokes are.
But to even have that argument about that,
well it seems easier than it really is.
And it seems like you're just
a guy who was talking about um,
it does,
right?
It does.
It seems what I thought,
I thought it was real
fucking easy for I did it.
I thought that too,
even about podcasting because podcasting
also made me really understand and
appreciate conversations
because conversations are
like a little dance between
robot Dick
pump conversations are a
little dance between people.
There's even a 10.
There's a marine to do it.
People don't always sync
up that good with it.
Like sometimes people,
it's awkward,
you know,
with some folks it's an art form though.
Look Dude,
I didn't realize how radio,
like it's the same as like comedy when I,
when I would start to have
to be on people's radio
shows and I realized there's
like a thing to it.
I just always assumed,
um,
fuck.
I was definitely a thing
to being entertaining when
you're having a long form
conversation,
you know the people that think that would
be easy to keep a conversation going.
I've never done it to know what's
the comedian saying?
I'm so high.
What's the comedian's name
that just passed away from mom?
The last boy scout.
He was on my show twice.
Fast boy scout.
Yeah,
he's in every movie.
He's from a punchline.
The guy go and add a yard dog.
I don't have no idea who taught fine.
I forget his name.
I'm a comedian.
Just passed away and he's my friend.
I'm telling you.
So Hi,
I'm blank.
And he came on the show twice.
Um,
fucking [inaudible] and he's like in
everything in the 80s he's an all these
eighties matters do come in.
No,
he's a kind of swore the swarthy move on.
I'm gonna look them up right now.
No,
it is Jeremy.
Yeah,
Taylor Taylor.
Negra.
These are strong,
that guy.
So he came on my podcast twice.
That guy was so fucking good.
Like that's all where I know
him from coming on there.
He would just wait for his part to jump
in and then he had something funny and
interesting to say and he'd jump
out and it was just amazing.
Like he just dancing and it was never in
somebody's way and it was always worth
like paying attention to like,
I thought he was like really killer.
There's a good dude too.
I used to always run
into him at the Improv.
Very,
very nice guy.
Very Fun guy.
Yeah,
he was one of the coolest guys.
I only met him like breezy,
but like I really liked them and
I really want him to come back.
I had no idea he had cancer or anything.
Oh,
somehow in another,
it's better than suicide,
you know?
That's the bummer when a
guy like Robin Williams,
Richard Jail Somehow or another,
that to me is like,
God damn it.
Somebody didn't get to
those dudes in time,
you know?
Well,
it's an IRA.
It's got to be some
kind of mental illness,
right,
because you're supposed to
be wired not to do that.
Oh yeah,
a hundred percent depression wired.
By the way.
Everybody says wired like,
where's my wires?
Like the Internet is tubes.
It's the same level of stupid
cause just is the way we're wired.
It's not tubes,
but is it,
I mean there's something
that goes across the ocean,
which is new to me.
Tapes and tunnel.
So I know fiber optic lines.
I didn't know they had to lay lines
across the entire fucking actual ocean.
I was like,
wait a minute.
I thought we were Wifi by now.
That's ridiculous.
But that's how we connect to
the other parts of the world.
They have a tube right to water
the seeds of tubes essentially.
But it's,
you know,
like if you ask the average person,
he uses the Internet to put up
Instagram pics of their ass.
How exactly is this getting to Sweden?
Because someone in Sweden right now
is downloading your Instagram feed.
Someone is looking at your butt pictures
while you're doing squats and these are
like a snapchat thing,
putting your butt up like that.
I thought snapchats fat to get your dig
up and then it goes away after a few
minutes we'll,
snapchat does.
But Instagram,
there's girls that have literally millions
and millions of followers and they're
just girls in yoga pants and all
they do all day is like squat.
That's my new,
how's the new port search?
I've been using yoga pants.
That's the porn search.
The dogs,
my new wine.
Am I dead soul of having to
find something to amuse me?
What will make my Dick to anything new?
Shit that Jack took her pants.
There's something about a girl who's
like really spiritual that still wants to
fuck guys get very excited.
Plus it's tight.
So it kind of compress the pants
can be really always ripped
the pants open.
Oh,
crazy.
Like violent but little consent.
She said,
so may I rip your pants
open or does this discussed?
I think it's important cause I'm not,
I'm not jerking off to rape.
I mean she doesn't turn
her face away from it.
She's not,
he's right into it.
I think that's consent.
I don't think you understand consent.
There's a part of the problem,
percent of communication is nonverbal.
So how I feel about it?
You are cisgender.
Yeah,
Dude.
Fuck yes,
you're cisgendered.
Um,
so therefore a privileged,
do not apologize for your very existence.
He probably will.
That's like the original sin now,
right?
That's your new flux.
Yes.
Sin when he just amongst a very small
chains to go that full circle to like
trying to get away from the circumstances
of your birth and now it's fully that
now like first we judge you by what your
category is before you say anything.
So now two different things.
Me,
it's different.
If he says it,
then you said it.
Well,
it's like that video that you were,
were listening to that Jamie was doing,
were you on the opie and Anthony show
that I was telling you about it where it's
like,
that's what you're,
you guys are like mocking that very thing.
Right,
right,
right.
I,
uh,
he's the,
his videos are the best God,
the amazing tone as if he's like patiently
talking to a fucking waterhead Gil
[inaudible] to you.
How you should react.
Okay guys,
that's the entire sense of humor.
They have to,
it's like,
you know,
someone raising one eyebrow
over their glasses at you.
Really?
That's their little like,
like a polite,
like a disdain or a,
I don't know.
Describe that sled nerd.
A contemptuous nerd is the
new kind of sense of humor.
But this is a big audience for that.
Yeah.
For like eye rolling.
I was like just professional.
I really ever saw pot and pan
has some great joke about a,
an altercation that happens in a Starbucks
in Los Filez where he says you could
barely hear the Nora Jones
song from the Saturday Aioli
is drowning.
Yes.
That was really slow description of,
of,
of reality.
It's so funny.
That is so vibrant,
but it's like that attitude bad.
It's like you don't,
it's all de this is Duh.
Right,
but you talking to
five-year-old's cause you,
you should need,
need to have a kid.
But that's what's so irritating about.
And also,
well,
I don't have,
they're confusing the role of comedy,
like comedy.
I guess it can be a tool for
whatever can be that doesn't,
it's not what it is.
You're not Batman with this.
Yeah.
You're the joker.
Babby is serious.
You're a,
you're a comedian.
You're the gene I trying to do good.
You trying to show Batman not
to take shit so seriously.
If you are trying to,
you should have a real point like,
hey,
here's something I found out about
that you need to make a drug with drug.
It will fucking kill you,
my friend.
You could take your points and,
and put them in joke form,
which is what your actual job is.
You guys will just cover go.
My sister's anti gay and
I think that's wrong.
Great Job Jamie.
You fucking rarely does he do that.
He did that on fucking Conan or something.
What is something he was on?
I was just like,
not a joke.
It's just him fucking preachings
and he retired though.
He's done right.
He's done with cotton.
I heard he retired really well.
Somebody tweeted I it
might just be temporary.
What's he gonna do for
money then to sand radio.
But he did he try to get you fired?
No.
But,
uh,
he,
he like threw in his own like,
yeah.
Something,
but it was mainly that one girl whose
name I don't imagine good for you and
fucking good for you.
But,
uh,
the,
I don't know,
man.
I just hate comics turning on
each other like that over jokes.
It's like the idea that you
were pretending you don't
know the guy's fucking
around and that that's an art.
There's an art form to go in
and see a guy who sang things.
You absolutely know.
He doesn't really believe.
Well,
look,
you have to your look.
I've kind of that fight already with,
you know,
and the bottom line is
everything's propaganda.
I remember this whole mindset,
dude,
everything is like church.
Yeah.
I know that mindset.
Like what kind of world
are you working for it?
These chokes Joe.
I mean,
think about that.
You know,
like,
like we weren't supposed to stumble.
I was talking about on
Marin's show the fucking like,
you couldn't stumble your
brother out of Christianity.
That was like a big no,
no.
In my church.
So let's,
I know your brother.
Yeah.
Like,
let's say you had some doubts about
something that you heard and like doctrine
and you set it to your brother
Rogan and brother row goes like,
yeah,
that sounds like bullshit.
I'm leaving this church.
You stumbled him out of
the faith with your shit.
You're supposed to humbly just
assume that whatever it is,
we'll get worked out and not
really make a stink about it.
Even if you didn't agree with something,
you go like,
well,
they know what's for the best.
That's actively,
you're supposed to do that.
Okay,
so these people at the same thing,
but by you making some crass joke about
something that's serious that people
don't take seriously enough,
you're contributing.
You understand the same way hip hop is
making young black men because of the hip
hop or fucking,
well,
it's,
it's the same fucking argument or how
dungeons and dragons is encouraging the
suicide or when it's the season.
It's an old argument.
Does anybody really say that?
What the dungeons and dragons,
don't you remember that in the eighties
dungeon dragons leads to suicide,
a demon ism and fucking,
there's always a thing
that you got to blame.
I'm telling you jokes one way or another
are never going to affect anything for
anything.
Like don't worry about the jokes.
You know the people who think Bush got
elected because of SNLs portrayal of Bush
versus their portrayal of Gore.
I've heard people,
oh,
what's his name,
who was on a Horatio Sanz said it.
He thought the election got affected
by my will Ferrell doing Bush that you
know,
condescending.
That is,
I think he's funny too.
Like I'm not against it,
but that's the most,
that's,
that's how they,
they're so condescending.
They imagine people were
swayed by Saturday night
live and people are so stupid
that they need,
they're gentle fucking lefty hands.
Do you understand?
Yeah,
but hold on a second because you're
talking to me from a guy who used to be a
fucking Jehovah's witness.
So you're talking about an entire religion
that believes unbelievably retarded
nonsense.
And you're surprised,
but you're surprised that a
portrayal by someone of a,
a president could influence
people that watch television.
I don't think anyone's switched their
vote because they saw jokes about you can
make it that possible though.
Not a ball point.
No,
I don't think they're responsible.
I don't think the person's response,
look,
people are retarded,
dude.
I don't think you could sway someone
who was people who voted for Bush.
We're into.
Okay,
and that,
that ideology,
the people's Idi,
it's the same as he's left.
He's like,
you wouldn't joke them
out of believing in shit.
They believe if the dumbest outliers,
it's possible.
I think if you could talk somebody
into being a scientologist talk,
someone in devoting,
here's what,
here's what I'll say to that.
If you're that fucking stupid
shouldn't be without work.
You probably didn't make it out to vote.
I'd be willing to bet you
didn't make it out to vote,
but the problem is stupid.
People are often very motivated.
It's mostly,
you see what the Westboro
Baptist church prays for it.
They're not stupid.
They're crazy.
They're dumb.
Then the ups guy was dumb.
He was a lawyer.
He was a civil rights attorney,
but he was still an idiot.
It was socially okay that,
yeah,
but that's not the same as stupid
and like that's a different kind of,
that's like a almost willful,
I don't have to be stupid,
but I am.
Well,
he's smart enough to memorize all the
shit that you needed to learn to become a
lawyer.
But as far as like,
I love them too.
First of all,
he was a civil rights lawyer.
He fought right when he got,
he got major breakthroughs
for black people.
I look it up.
He did something really nice.
He Dude,
the best part of this is,
yeah,
it's weird.
They concentrate on this one rule,
but they just saying what's in the Bible.
That's my favorite part because all
these people out there think no,
you can moderate the,
you always say that moderate shit.
So I have news for you.
If you're a moderate,
they need,
you're not in it.
You full of Shit.
Okay.
That people that are really
doing it are the extreme ones.
It's not a part time thing.
So that's why I don't do it anymore
because I'm not going to half ass do it.
So I like those people that because
literally the Bible says only a few people
are going to survive.
That's why America is not Christian.
If America,
we are all Christian,
that we wouldn't be
Christian automatically.
It's built in only a small few find the
Crampton narrow road leading to eternal
life and the road leading
to destruction is massive.
And that's where most of the people go.
So the though they think they're
those few that are on the cramp,
the road,
much like a virgin butthole,
she'd be so really the idea of a
Christian nation is impossible.
Yeah.
I don't know what Bible
people are reading your caves,
you dumb dumb book.
Do you not look at it and say the same
people that Tattoo Bible verses on your
body?
Like,
dude,
you got to read the whole book.
I just said,
I watched,
I watched some redneck go,
well you were not under that law anymore.
I watch some redneck on some go.
Uh,
yeah,
I was.
I'm Christian.
So I was raised to fight when
I forgot what I believe it.
I say the exact opposite
of being Christian.
You fucking Dick head will
people pick and choose.
They pick and choose
where they don't play.
Certainly it's like divorce.
You're supposed to stone the
woman if you get divorced,
you know if the woman leaves here,
that's it for adultery.
There's a lot of terrible
fucking shit in there,
but that was a lot of it.
You can absolutely justify with it was
for the time was somewhat progressive.
Right?
When you talk about,
okay you can own slaves like well it
wasn't the kind of slavery we had at the
time.
They were nicer about say like,
okay that's fine,
but you're telling me that this,
this book's exceptional so why aren't,
why aren't they in the future?
Like if the word shoe,
God invented this shit itch,
you'd be like,
oh way ahead of its time.
We're like,
we're the ones that don't have slaves
cause we have the one true God.
Why is it like that?
Because I'm supposed to have them judging.
I'm supposed to before I just do anything.
Imagine one of them,
like one of the profits
is alive watching me.
What would he would of Moses were here?
What would he think of what I'm doing?
I'm supposed to do that.
And as a Christian,
but I'm not supposed to judge
Moses for h Shinny Shit.
Right?
[inaudible] was a killer.
I like,
yeah,
I never killed anybody.
Moses.
And also I don't have slaves.
So you could save your
judgment of my fucking,
you know,
well,
just a few hundred years ago,
if you go back and read some of
this stuff that like Lincoln,
we read this passage by
Linkedin the other day.
Oh,
I love him.
I love those passages there.
They're crazy.
I want them in the hall of
presidents at Disneyland.
I want Lincoln be like,
Oh,
I'm not advocating or quality for
the Negro will all have a say.
Not wanting them to,
they shouldn't be allowed
to vote to hold office,
uh,
or be able to intermarry with whites.
Like this was all like him in a debate.
Yeah.
But that's his,
that's his like compromising
to try to make it,
it's like,
oh,
his Obamacare.
It's not a perfect solution,
but we had to do something.
That's what that shit is probably,
I guess back then as we were saying that,
it was probably like super
radical progressive for the
time I was fighting with
Gavin.
You Know Gavin,
right?
Gavin McInnes.
I know who he is,
so we went to,
what are they talking about?
Slavery.
I live in fucking you guys going back
and slavery's not that bad or that the
civil wars and how bad slavery
there would be no civil war.
If there had been no slavery,
they wouldn't have gone to
war over cotton tariffs,
tariffs.
They could've worked that out.
Black Dick on the Lewis was,
trust me a big fucking factor.
And if you took it out,
no war.
Absolutely so black Dick
on the loose you feel,
of course.
Do you think they're going to like,
you're going to free all these slaves we
haven't beaten and they're going to be
just like us and you're
going to be fucking our kids.
Well,
don't you think that the biggest fear
was that they would lose the economic
impact of having slaves?
Well,
that was the lowest.
That's for,
that's your rich man's
motive for [inaudible].
You ever see like poor
man's road of his is like,
oh now the blacks are coming from mine.
That's my one thing I have that.
It's a very simple fucking thing.
But they always get it
soft sell it like no,
there was more to the conf wake.
Let's say there's no slavery.
The confederacy is still sucked,
but he's still fucking traders.
It's not like if you fucking,
how are they traitors Prentice split
up the union over some bullshit.
Right,
but why it should they give into the
fucking whims of the north and north of
there?
Fuck it.
Cities.
That's what essentially was going on too.
That was a big part of what
was happening back then.
There was two different lifestyles.
The north,
which was about like cities,
right?
And there's a south that was like
agriculture and most when they were saying
like,
oh it's about economics.
Well yeah you,
you have a bunch of people
that are working for free
and they would like to aid
and you know,
they want to keep paying them.
Nothing that would have
just ended it on its own.
Yeah.
Eventually give up having free labor
sill.
Who said that about Brazil?
The Brazil did it without
killing 600 this fucking guy.
I go,
listen,
was Hiroshima necessary?
Then the civil war was necessary.
Okay.
If you're going to justify
dropping the atom bomb,
which I do,
then yeah,
600 if I'm asleep,
if I'm ever a slave,
by all means kill half a million southern.
There's,
until I'm free,
by all means,
I'm willing to sacrifice them
for me to not be a slave.
So this guy,
oh,
it's like,
it's all these shit that's
easy for you to say.
If you're not a slave,
that's where the bottom fucking line,
and they just won't put
themselves in those shoes ever.
It's gotta be like the ultimate showed up.
Black people.
That's the whole fucking
point of that flag.
We're being a care.
If it bothers you,
you'll never get that from us.
It's a weird pride thing.
It's like,
what exactly are you proud of?
You lost a war.
We were trying to separate from the
people that didn't want slavery.
Is it you're proud of the
spot where you were born,
which you had no control
over a young dude.
I don't want you to understand flags.
You know,
I couldn't salute the flag when I was
growing up because I know that's going to
fault them for neutral and all politics.
If you're Joe was witness,
you don't get involved in politics.
So you don't vote at all?
No.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's,
I don't give a shit what
Satan's system of things does.
Is it gonna be all wiped out.
Oh,
I see.
But anyway,
so I never,
I never got attached to a flag like that.
Like I never understood because I got
to be ever felt that feeling of like a
flag,
even though now I'm like,
I'm way into America,
but I,
I couldn't ever like just be into a flat.
It's so something so gross about that.
Well it is kinda gross and it's,
it's gross just by way of all all
definitions that are like confining.
Like if you can find yourself like,
no,
I'm American.
It's fucking Mexicans trying
to come over here to our land.
Imagine if you were saying,
hey man,
I'm from California and those fuckers
from Nevada trying to come over to
California,
we're going to kill him.
No,
you go over to Nevada and
there's just other Americans.
So like,
hey,
how you doing?
But if you go right,
right,
instead of left,
all of a sudden you're in a place where
people all look exactly the fucking
same.
Yes.
He's not going to do a ton of
Mexicans in Nevada and they're like,
hey,
what's up brother?
What are you doing man?
What's going on?
Everything's cool.
Everything's normal.
You're talking to them
like they're your friends.
They're fellow Americans.
But that,
yeah,
go right.
And then the,
they're the what?
The enemy.
What are they?
Are they an ally or they
can't come over here.
Well,
people don't seem to realize that
whatever immigrants it is like,
it's not like if they learn English
that if their kids learn English or
something,
you know what I mean?
[inaudible] generation.
Ron.
Yeah.
But she,
you know,
I was surprised because
she fest cause I go,
my whole thing is can you just go to
wherever who is hiring illegals and go and
see everyone's paperwork and then penalize
the company for doing that and then
problem solve.
There's no more jobs for them.
And she's like,
yeah,
no the corporations or the one
of the biggest promoters of it.
But so,
so bill Maher made a good point.
He was like,
you should have called the book that how
corporations are fucking it up because
people are just going to dismiss your
points now cause you just blamed it on the
white blame the IMEC.
Why would I not come here and try
and get a job if I needed one?
Why would I not?
That's just a radical
hot button topic though.
Blaming it on immigrants.
Like people love doing that because
I think to get people on your side,
if there's like a few key components,
you're not going to touch my guns.
You know,
fucking immigration has ruined
this country's foreign country.
We go to worry about,
oh we got porous.
But it's such an eternal argument,
man.
It sounds so bill the butcher,
when they throw in potatoes,
that Irish people coming off the boat,
you know,
it sounds just like that.
Like you just sound like the same shit.
People all want the same
shit they want to have.
Like they'll fucking middleclass home
and all that and you can see it every
fucking race that comes here
that that gets to that level.
They kind of just live like TV
sitcoms people because I mean,
exactly.
That's what most people,
there's only a few of them where they
try to fucking set themselves apart and
they're mostly white cuckoo religions.
Yeah.
It's,
it's real hard when you try to
see like how robot Dick Again,
I think it's distracting as fuck.
Oh yeah.
I like how you lean back.
I said,
well I can still hear it though.
And your ears.
You must know.
Oh,
soothing me Jerry.
Try the gum.
The Gum.
I was just like getting bigger,
darker objects to put into my mouth.
Dude.
They gave us one that was so stupid.
We still have that
stupid thing around here.
Jamie.
He's in the back,
the back there.
They give me,
uh,
you've seen that one?
That yeah,
it looks like a light saber.
It looks retarded.
It literally,
it literally looks like a weapon.
I know.
They construct it in
themselves like lightsabers.
It was huge.
And it was,
you had to refill it though.
Every like 10 hits or something.
Do that.
The squirt into the cotton and everything.
What are you doing?
I didn't use cotton.
It's a mess.
Every time I do it,
I need some tissues so I got to an eye
dropper is shit now the battery ran out
so I got a spare battery in his car.
Oh my God.
You're a junkie.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's not like killing me.
How cigarettes are killing,
I mean seconds be killing me man.
I could feel it.
It was horrible.
You could feel it like
eating away at your health.
Oh yeah.
So I don't feel like that no more.
Brian,
how long have you been off now?
For three weeks.
I'm proud of you,
dude.
That's really strong.
That's very strong.
I'm glad you made it that far,
man.
Just keep going.
You think you're free now?
Yeah,
I'm just bored.
but do you think you're free where
you'll stop smoking for now on?
Yeah,
it seems get it.
I really hope so.
I'll do it.
I used to,
I really worried about you.
I was like,
I'm going to get the call one day from
that guy and he's going to say I have
cancer and I'm,
I'm like,
I can't even tell you.
I tried to get you to
quit for 10 fucking years.
It was up to two packs.
Awesome
dude.
It's the guy who the store,
everybody smokes there
and they're all just,
when I saw companies,
when I started smoking,
yeah,
the store is a real bad.
It's better than the Improv is not
as bad as far as like mountain.
The laugh factory is not bad at all
because there's nowhere to smoke.
If the fact that the
comedy store has a patio,
you could smoke it so like you're sitting
there and people were just blowing
smoke in your face.
Non Style.
That's an interesting thing.
I've never thought about
what the laugh factor.
The factor doesn't have anything.
They don't have a place
where you can go with that.
Improv kind of has like that parking
lot type parking lot is great.
I'm out there all the time.
No,
no.
I'm off until Thursday.
I'm doing a store Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
Oh,
okay.
Let me show you around you motherfucker.
I know.
I want to see do some standup in town.
I haven't seen you since Montreal.
We were at that little tiny club.
The comedy works.
He's an ex Jehovah's witness to the older,
yeah,
the Highlander.
But he's not a business that closes going,
but why did it go under?
I don't know cause I used to
love going and hanging out there,
man.
I ain't no dude.
That was a great call.
Oh,
can I get a lot of listeners right?
Yeah.
Cause stress factory in New Brunswick
on July 23rd through 25th excellent.
If you're out there,
come see me at the stress factory.
Beautiful.
Do that.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
If you haven't seen Kurt Metzger,
plug your ears so I can talk.
Nice about you.
Very,
very funny guy.
That's why I really wanted to
see you while you were in town.
Yeah,
man,
I've been wanting to come on for awhile.
Fucker.
How often he around here?
Uh,
it depends on what work I have.
I had a press junket to do
and your podcast is on iTunes.
People can get it on everything.
Cloud.
Itunes.
Yeah.
It's called race wars
with Kurt and Charlotte.
I'm going to subscribe right now.
I heard great things about the hertz.
Really funny stuff is still came out.
It was one of our better ones,
but sometimes it's the people talking
over each other and show that happens.
Well,
it's not as easy as it looks.
I agree with you.
You know what I saw the other day?
Somebody put up a video of a dead mouse.
Eddie Bravo,
Russell Peters,
me and you doing a podcast.
Remember that podcast that we did?
All the talking over each other.
We were all hammered so bad.
It's so hard to listen to fucking,
yeah,
so hard to listen to.
Yeah.
That happens a lot with
the ice house chronicles.
It's one of the most annoying thing.
Did you see?
We've had as many,
like seven or eight people and
I'm like [inaudible] before.
Did you see the Paris
Hilton I prank video?
No,
they got to go though.
I have to go.
Unfortunately I have
to leave Paris Hilton.
There's Egyptian guy,
a prankster where they're in an airplane
and they made the airplane like,
like nose dive and stuff like that.
And now she's like,
she's like,
I fly all the time and now I'm scared
to be on a plane going to swamp.
She's uh,
she's allowed to sue I guess.
Unfortunately I have to
end this thing early.
I got,
oh,
I got an obligation but a Kurt Metzger.
Thank you very much for coming in.
We're going to be on Sirius to I come on.
How do we do it?
We Skype or uh,
yeah.
What do you want?
Anytime you want to do that we can what?
I'll see you out here.
Do you do it live out here?
Over,
I mean,
no,
we got it.
I want to do a tour with him.
Yeah,
sure.
I'll just do it man.
Listen Thompson Gara
and Christina Palicki,
Duncan Trussell,
they doing that thing on tour the country.
They do their podcasts on tour docking.
Loves it.
He said he loves it as much
as he loves doing standup.
Well,
I get a couple of live
ones are pretty fun,
man.
But,
uh,
I've done,
Diaz is live.
I've done killed Tony.
Brian's live.
That's a,
that's a lot of fun to do.
Kill Tony's.
Hilarious.
We've done that one.
Does I do that last night?
Oh,
that's right.
That's what,
that one was fun,
man.
We're out of here.
You fucks.
Uh,
we'll see you soon.
That's it for the week.
Uh,
be back on Monday.
Lots.
Lots of great shit.
Next week.
See Ya.
Five.
Oh,
thanks man.
Hm.